Herzlich Willkommen zu Alternativlos, die Folge numero 45. 45. Wir reden heute über offensive versus defensive Sicherheit. Da hat sich so ein bisschen was angestaut, was irgendwie so die allgemeine Security-Branche angeht und am Ende reden wir wahrscheinlich auch nochmal so ein bisschen über Epidemien, Viren, Prepping, Hamsterkäufe, also die ganzen Dinge, die man heute gerade so in der Presse sieht. Aber wir fangen erstmal an mit offensiver und defensiver Security.
Ja, also den Punkt habe ich auf die Liste gesetzt, weil ich neulich bei einer kleinen Konferenz war in Berlin, die DefensiveCon. Ja, und das ist ein Pann auf die OffensiveCon, die es auch gibt, die auch in Berlin ist. Und auf der OffensiveCon treffen sich so die ganzen Geheimdienste und exploit Broker und die Leute, die exploit schreiben. Und da geht es inzwischen um Millionenbeträge. Für so einen ein bisher unbekannten exploit gegen sagen wir Windows oder IOS ist richtig Kohle wert inzwischen. Also da geht es um Geld. Und das ist auch sozusagen die dieselben Leute, bei denen sich dann unsere Regierung bedienen müsste, wenn sie tatsächlich Hackback machen wollen, was jetzt auch ein Thema war in den letzten Wochen und Monaten. Ja, die OffensiveCon da treffen sich halt so die schmierigen Kriminellen. Will ich die mal hier alle abkanzeln, da sind auch nette Leute bei, die ich kenne. Aber so im Wesentlichen sind das Kriminelle. Und das liegt daran, dass unsere Regierung den Besitz von exploits kriminalisiert hat.
Meinst du, das hat die Leute in die in den Untergrund getrieben, in die Fänge der Exploit-Broker getrieben?
Naja, den Begriff Exploit-Broker und den Beruf gab es ja auch gar nicht früher, weil es keinen Markt gab. Doch, klar. Früher, früher konntest du dein Scheiß direkt irgendwie an Geheimdienste verkloppen. Da musstest du keinen Broker nehmen.
Na ja, aber so Leute, die halt irgendwie die Kontakte in die Szene gehalten haben und da dann halt irgendwie das Zeug aufgekauft haben, gab es schon immer.
Naja, Moment, also es gibt ja sozusagen, es gibt ja zwei Exploit-Szenen. Es gibt einmal so eine Semi-Normale, so mit halbwegs seriösen Anbietern, die dann so was machen wie auf einer Konferenz irgendwie ein Auto hinstellen und wer es gehackt kriegt, darf damit wegfahren. Ja, so was gibt es.
Das ist dann zu seriös.
Naja, das ist das seriöse Ende des Spektrums.
Also diese Pwn2own.
genau, Pwn2own. Und auf der anderen Seite gibt es halt so Geheimdienste und ein Geflecht aus Firmen, die sich gegenseitig Exploits unter Verschleierung der Quelle verkaufen. Und wenn du richtig Asche machen willst, dann würdest du wahrscheinlich zu solchen Leuten gehen. Also hängt jetzt natürlich davon ab, welcher Art von Exploit du in der Tasche hast. Aber so die Blackheads sind die mit den tiefen Taschen. Das sind die Geheimdienste und BKA aus dieser Welt. Und die Zulieferer von denen sind halt keine normalen Exploitschreiber, sondern niemand will mit denen direkt reden, weil das halt kriminell ist eigentlich. Und niemand glaubt jemandem wie dem Geheimdienst, dass sie dich dann nicht einsperren, wenn du denen einen Exploit verkaufst, so nach dem Motto, gib mal her den Exploit, aber bezahlen müssen wir dich ja nicht, weil so ist halt kriminell, jetzt sowas zu haben. Und es gibt auch vielleicht nicht gewissen so Ethik, aber schon das Gefühl, ne, das sind nicht gute Leute, mit denen man da Geschäfte macht. Und da will man so jemand dazwischen haben.
Nimmst du dir halt so einen Broker, der dir dann irgendwie einredet, dass er nur an die Guten verkauft oder wie?
genau. Naja, viele, viele sagen gar nicht an wen sie verkaufen, dann weißt du schon.
Aber mittlerweile ist es doch so, dass irgendwie eine ganze Menge, also gerade was die Amis so haben und so, da gibt es auch so Dienstleisterfirmen halt hier irgendwie so was, wie heißen die? Endgame und so, die halt irgendwie im Wesentlichen sich darauf spezialisiert haben, Exploits gezielt zu entwickeln und zu suchen für die Plattform, wo es gerade am meisten Kohle gibt.
Ja, das ist so ein bisschen metastasierend. Was es da alles für Jobs und Firmen gibt, die noch am sichtbarsten sind, so Firmen, die zum Beispiel Forensik-Software für Telefone verkaufen an den Zoll und so. Und die behaupten halt gerne, dass sie ihre Exploits selber schreiben, aber die werden die wahrscheinlich auch irgendwo einkaufen. Und es gibt Firmen, die sich darauf spezialisiert haben, Exploits zu schreiben und dann meist bieten zu verscheuern. Aber der gesamte Markt ist im Grunde kriminell. Denn du kannst dich nicht darauf verlassen, dass den Exploit, den du gerade exklusiv gekauft hast, dass tatsächlich nur du den gekauft hast.
Deswegen gibt es ja diese Brunnen, die halt dann unter exklusiven Kontakt für irgendeinen Geheimdienst arbeiten. Also die, also ich hab da mittlerweile von mehreren gehört, die halt häufig von so ex-NSA-Leuten gegründet werden, die halt verstanden haben, wie der Hase läuft und dann halt gezielt in Produkten und Softwareversionen nach Fehlern suchen, die halt von ihrem ehemaligen Arbeitgeber gerne für viel Geld aufgekauft werden.
genau. Aber das ist ja ein alter Hut sozusagen, dass Leute mit Spezialwissen rausgehen aus den Konzernen oder der Behörde.
Nee, aber interessant daran fand ich halt, dass man sich so ein paar anguckt, wie zum Beispiel diese Franzosen und so. Die haben ja mittlerweile so ein Kontinuitäts-Businessmodell entwickelt, dass sie sagen so, du kaufst als Kunde Access auf eine Exploit-Pipeline.
Ein Abo.
genau, ein Abo.
kaufst ein Abo bei uns.
Ein Abo, was halt irgendwie mit, manchmal klappt es halt nicht, aber meistens hast du halt immer mindestens einen funktionierenden, einer funktionierenden Exploit-Chain. Mittlerweile sind sie ja nicht mal als eine Exploit, sondern als Exploit-Chains, weil halt die Security auf den Plattformen ein bisschen besser geworden ist, was irgendwie so Privilegien, Eskalationen und so angeht. Du kannst halt immer sicher sein, wenn du so ein Abo kaufst, dass du halt irgendwie mindestens für jede Android-Version und alle wesentlichen iOS-Versionen halt und Windows und Wattnot halt irgendwie und die Browser und irgendwie WhatsApp und so weiter, dann halt jeweils irgendwie einen Exploit in der Pipeline hast, der irgendwie zumindest gerade funktioniert. So manchmal halt nicht.
Das ist zumindest die werbeaussage.
Ja gut, aber wenn man sich so anguckt, was die so treiben, dann sind, also was die ja machen, ist ja quasi so Aggregation. Das heißt also, die sammeln halt irgendwie aus der Szene Zeug ein, entwickeln zum Teil Zeug selber, kaufen es auf und repackagen es. Indem sie halt die Tools drum rum dann halt irgendwie an ihre Geheimdienstkunden verkaufen für relativ viel Geld, aber eben halt als Subscription Service.
Da muss man vielleicht auch sagen, die Sachen sind unterschiedlich riskant. Also die, wenn man jetzt losläuft und sagt, ich finde jetzt einen Bug, der exploitbar ist, das ist relativ hohes Risiko, dass es nichts wird. Weil die Plattformen inzwischen ordentlich Mitigation haben und die Sachen werden ja schneller gepatcht, als man braucht, um so einen Bug zu finden. Das heißt, das ist eine Sache. Das Risiko machen hauptsächlich Einzelpersonen. Es gibt auch Firmen, die das machen, aber Firmen kaufen gerne Lücken und entwickeln dann den exploit, der auf allen Plattformen, Versionen funktioniert selbst oder würden es gerne, weil das ist ein Teil des Weaponizing. Den kann man nicht automatisieren, aber so fast. Also da ist zwar Aufwand mit verbunden, aber nicht das selten Risiko, dass es nicht geht, weil man einen exploit, einen Bug kauft, von dem man weiß, dass er exploitbar ist. Das lässt man sich vorführen auf mindestens einer Version und dann den Rest der anderen exploits für die anderen Plattformen, Versionen baut man selbst. Das ist häufig das Geschäftsmodell. Ja, aber das sind halt, wie gesagt, alles Kriminelle und es gibt auch keine Zusagen. Also selbst wenn die Firma, die dir den Bug verkauft, dir zusagt, dass sie das Keim anderen verkauft und selbst wenn sie das auch tatsächlich tun, heißt es nicht, dass irgendjemand anders nicht den selben Bug finden. Also die Zusage gibt es nicht. Und wenn der erste den Bug genutzt hat, dann ist der im Grunde verbrannt für alle, die ihn kennen. Das heißt, das Geschäftsmodell für so eine Behörde.
Aber tatsächlich muss man ja sagen, der allergrößte Teil der Sachen, die in The Wild passieren, sind uralte Scheißversionen. Uralte Scheißversionen, insofern dieses, dann ist der für alle anderen verbrannt, gilt doch eigentlich nur gegen wirkliche High-End-Targets, die halt also wirklich ihren Scheiß im Griff haben und perfektes Monitoring auf allen Systemen haben und die wirklich mitbekommen, wenn da jemand mit einem bisher unbekannten Exploit ihnen die Büchse aufmacht und dann in der Lage sind halt die, die Anzeichen für diesen Exploit zu isolieren. Das sind doch relativ wenige.
Ja und nein. Also auf der einen Seite ja, auf der anderen Seite haben wir halt inzwischen häufig selbst patchende Systeme. Und wir haben eine Menge Telemetrie da draußen. Eine Sache, auf die ich auch noch eingehen wollte in diesem Podcast. Das heißt, wenn du ein Exploit gegen, sagen wir mal, Google Chrome hast oder so, der irgendwie in der nicht-stable-Version wöchentlich geupdatet wird, dann selbst, wenn die den Bug nicht gefunden haben, ist es einfach wahrscheinlich, dass dein Exploit nicht mehr geht im nächsten Update, weil die Offsets ein bisschen anders sind. Also das heißt, das Weaponisen von Exploits kann kaputt gehen, selbst wenn niemand dein Bug gefunden hat. Und der Trend in der gesamten Industrie geht dahin, A, Mitigations zu haben, das heißt sozusagen, das Exploiten schwieriger zu machen. Also nicht den Bug nicht zu haben, was ja meine favorisierte Lösung wäre, sondern dafür zu sorgen, wenn jemand den Bug findet, dass dann das Ausnutzen schwierig oder riskant ist und häufig nicht funktioniert. So und das ist erschütternd erfolgreich, muss man sagen. Also ich war immer ein Feind davon, weil ich mir dachte, das setzt falsche Anreize. Ja, wenn du so Mitigations heißt, dann musst du ja die ganzen Bugs nicht mehr fixen und das kann man auch beobachten. Aber diese Mitigations sind inzwischen eigentlich gut genug, dass in der Praxis tatsächlich die meisten Exploits an den Mitigations scheitern. Und das verschiebt auch die interessanten Ziele. Das heißt, du hast heutzutage einfach eine, es gab da eine schöne Analyse zu, die sagt, okay, die Kosten für die Exploit-Entwicklung sind sehr hoch, aber die Folgekosten für den nächsten Exploit sind nicht so hoch. Weil du dann ein ganzes Tooling hast. Das heißt, was praktisch passiert, ist, dass wir die Menge der Leute, die in der Lage sind, so einen Exploit zu entwickeln, einschränken auf Geheimdienste. Also Leute mit viel, die genug Kohle haben, um das Initialinvestment zu machen, oder halt so ein paar Nerds, die das schon sich vorher gebastelt hatten.
Aber es gibt doch reichlich irgendwie so Post-Exploitation-Toolkits und so, die halt irgendwie dann, die du benutzen kannst, um dann auf dem System resident zu werden.
Ja, das ist aber der, der sozusagen der Teil, nachdem du da schon ein Fuß in der Tür hast. Der schwierige Teil ist, den Fuß in die Tür zu kriegen. Also dann, wenn du auf dem System Code ausführen kannst, deine Privilegien im System zu erweitern und so, diese Art von Bug gibt es viel häufiger. Und gerade mit dem Argument, dass das ja nur dann wichtig ist, wenn jemand schon Fuß in der Tür hat, werden die auch gerne runterprävisiert und dann jahrelang nicht geschlossen. Also da gibt es deutlich weniger Knappheit an lokalen Privilege Escalation, so heißen die, als an Remote Privilege Escalation oder Remote Code Execution. Das sind so die richtig teuren Bugs, wenn jemand sozusagen dir irgendwie ein Paket schickt übers Netzwerk und dann irgendwie Sachen auf deinem Gerät tun kann. So, das sind die teuren Sachen. Das heißt, der interessante Teil ist eigentlich, wie komme ich überhaupt erst mal rein? Wenn ich dann drin bin, was ich da für Dinge tun kann, das ist sozusagen der gelöste und automatisierbare Teil. Da gibt es Frameworks, die man kaufen kann, die schon mit fertigen Exploit-Code kommen und auch separat gewartet werden, um das Investment zu verkleinern. Und die mietet man dann auch. Ja, das ist, also es ist wirklich das gesamte, das ist so, es ist genau, es ist alles nur noch SS Service, auch in der Security. Aber im Wesentlichen ist es so, dass die paar Leute, die noch wirklich Exploit selber entwickeln können, das sind halt nicht so viele. Und das sind im Wesentlichen Leute mit tiefen Taschen. Entweder weil sie schon mal einen Exploit verkauft haben und ordentlich kassiert haben oder weil es halt Geheimdienste sind. So, das heißt, die können schon eigene Exploits entwickeln. Haben sie auch gemacht. Dieses Eternal Blue haben sie zwar den Back gekauft, aber haben dann irgendwie ein Dutzend oder zwei Dutzend oder so verschiedene Varianten für verschiedene System Windows Versionen gehabt. Das machen dann schon die Dienste selber. So eigentlich wollten wir über die Defensive reden, aber die Offensive sieht halt so aus. Es gibt nicht mehr so viele Player, die da mitspielen können und die, die es können, sind von den Gesetzen in die Kriminalität getrieben worden. Daher gibt es jetzt schattige Zwischenschichten von Resellern und Brokern. Das sind so Leute, die dann tatsächlich irgendwie aus so einer Con aufschlagen und Leute in Puff einladen, damit sie irgendwie...
Aber es gibt doch irgendwie, wenn man sich die Systeme da draußen anguckt, die mit denen man so zu tun hat. Ganz viel davon ist das so Crap, wo du halt irgendwie echt kein Special-Sonder-Neuexploit brauchst, so weil du halt irgendwie... Da halt irgendwie dieses Gestapel von irgendwie JavaScript-Frameworks, die dynamisch nachgeladen werden und wo du halt irgendwie dich darauf verlässt, dass jetzt nicht irgendein Webhook schiefgeht. Das ist doch so der große Teil der Systeme, in denen heute unsere Daten liegen. Ich meine, so richtig so das Highend, so irgendwie, keine Ahnung, aktuelles iOS auf aktuellem iPhone oder aktuelles Android auf aktuellem Pixel-Phone. Klar, ich meine, aber das ist doch letzten Endes halt der Teil, wo zum einen immer noch Sachen irgendwie über, wie sagen wir mal, so Media-Player, hobs genommen werden, also und zwar reichlich, wo du halt irgendwie dann ein Video über WhatsApp zugeschickt bekommst und dann irgendwie eskaliert es halt einmal quer durch.
Da gibt es auch eine Begründung für übrigens, warum das so ein Ziel ist.
Weil halt extrem komplexe Fallformate, wo die Pase halt schwierig sind.
Aber nicht inherent komplex, sondern komplex, weil es ein Patentprozess ist, wo gerne jeder seinen Patent, also die treffen sich als Konsortium und dann sagt jeder irgendwie, pass auf, ich hab hier auch noch eine Idee, die machen wir auch noch als optional Feature rein. Oder nicht optional, das ist natürlich der, dann hast du gewonnen, wenn dein Feature nicht optional ist. Aber so ein typischer Decoder-Standard definiert dann so was wie Mainline-Level irgendwie eins bis fünf. Ja, und Komplexitätslevel des N und Decoders. Und je höher die Komplexität von N und Decoder, desto bessere Vorhersagen kann der treffen. Und das ist wie so ein Kompressor funktioniert, dass man eine Vorhersage trifft, was man glaubt, was im nächsten Bild kommt. Und dann speichert man nur noch die Änderungen gegenüber dem, also von dem tatsächlichen Inhalt gegenüber der Vorhersagen. Das heißt, dass es so komplex ist, liegt erstens daran, dass wir immer mehr CPU-Zeit haben, weil die CPUs immer schneller werden. Das heißt, wir können uns jetzt auch Decoder leisten, die so ein bisschen komplexer sind. Naja, das hat jahrelang Impact aufgehalten. Und das andere ist eben, dass es so ein Patent irgendwie free for all ist, wo jede Firma noch mal...
So ein Komitee-Ding, ne?
Das ist ein Komitee, genau. Und die treffen sich halt und dann gibt es keinen Anreiz dafür, den Standard klein zu halten. Im Gegenteil, jeder der Teilnehmer hat sich mit den anderen abgesprochen, dass das möglichst groß und komplex wird, damit jeder ein Stück vom Kuchen abkriegt. Ja, und jetzt gab es gerade nicht nur Video-Kodex, auch 5G ist so ein Ding. Da gab es gerade so eine Statistik, dass allein Huawei irgendwie 20.000 Patente hat, die auf 5G anwendbar sind. Das ist ja auch kein Zufall. Ja, sondern die Firmen versuchen alle so viele Patente wie möglich da in Stellung zu bringen. Und wenn du noch ein Patent reindrücken willst, dann baust du halt noch schnell einen Feature ein. Ja, wo das Patent braucht. So, das heißt, das ist eine selbstzugefügte Wunde, dass diese ganzen Komplexitäten uns aus den Händen wachsen, die unter anderem durch diese Patentscheiße verursacht wird. Und das führt aber dazu, dass häufig Sachen in den Standards drinstehen, die noch nie einer implementiert hat. Ja, weil die halt optional sind.
Na gut, wenn sie nicht implementiert sind, sind sie ja irgendwie wesentlich exploitbar. Aber, ich meine, was ich halt so...
Ja, Moment. Heute nicht. Aber es gab mehrere Fälle, wo dann irgendwie die nächste Version von dem Decoder plötzlich das Feature supportet hat und die war dann plötzlich kaputt. Ja, und das ist halt, ist halt scheiße. Das heißt, die Anreize sind überhaupt nicht in die Richtung gesetzt, dass wir hier jemals sichere Software kriegen, sondern im Gegenteil.
Na klar, ich meine jeder will halt versuchen, irgendwie seine Stellung am Markt möglichst durch Login halt irgendwie zu mehr voranzutreiben, indem Leute halt irgendwie auf ein Feature dann dependen, was nur von dir kommen kann.
Es gibt ja so in der Betriebswirtschaft, gibt es ja die Idee, dass du entweder verdienst, weil du ein Produkt baust und dann verkaufst du das und pro verkaufter Kopie kriegst du Geld oder du verdienst an deinem Besitz, was halt viel einfacher ist. Hier gehört irgendwie ein miethaus. Und die Softwarebranche hat jahrelang auf produktverkauf gesessen und schwenkt jetzt um auf Miete und Abo und as a service. Ja, und das heißt eben, dass sich auch die Infrastruktur ändert drumherum. So ist aber nicht nur negativ, denn das heißt jetzt, wenn jemand irgendwas als Service anbietet und da den Kundendaten verloren, hat er zum ersten Mal einen Anreiz, dass das ordentlich ist. Also da haben viele Leute Hoffnung gehabt, hat sich leider nicht so bewahrheit, das ist jedenfalls.
Nee, hat sich nicht bewahrheitet, weil es gibt ja keine Folgen. Also ich meine, das ist ja ein genaues Problem, dass irgendwie die in dem Augenblick, wo wenn irgendeine Firma deine Daten verliert, und du erst mal der erste Schritt bekommst du es mit, meistens bekommst du es nicht mit. Und wenn du es dann doch mitbekommst, weil du halt zum Beispiel halt eine unique E-Mail-Adresse pro Firma verwendest, und du siehst halt plötzlich, du kriegst halt Spam auf einer E-Mail-Adresse, die du halt nur bei dieser oder jeder Firma verwendet hast, dann ist eigentlich alles klar. Dann hast du trotzdem ja noch das Problem, dass die Leute interessiert es ja am Ende nicht, solange sie nicht wirklich irgendeine Art von messbarem oder fühlbaren Schaden haben.
Also ich hab gedacht, zumindest wenn du, sagen wir mal, als Firma in die Amazon-Cloud gehst und die Amazon-Cloud fällt dann aus, was ja gelegentlich passiert, dass das dann irgendwie dazu führt, dass die Leute da weglaufen. Aber nicht mal das ist der Fall. Im Gegenteil, man sieht, dass die Leute dann Double-Down machen. Dann gehen wir halt in noch ein anderes Amazon-Rechenzentrum auch rein und gehen vielleicht auch noch zu Microsoft Azure, dem Konkurrenten. Aber das heißt, dass es sozusagen für dich als Anbieter überhaupt keinen Grund gibt, das ordentlich zu machen. Außer, dass du vielleicht deine Service-Kosten verkleinern willst.
Na du musst sie erstellen.
Wenn du mal mit so einem Service da redest, hast du auch nicht den Eindruck, dass da noch was wegverkleinerbar ist.
Nein, du musst als Anbieter von solchen Services nur dafür sorgen, dass deine Log-in-Kraft, mit der du die Kunden an dich bindest, weil du zum Beispiel halt Apis hast, die nur du hast, wo dann der umstellungsaufwand für den Kunden relativ groß wäre, größer ist als das Gefühl des Kunden, dass du ihn leider scheiße behandelst oder der Infrastruktur halt leider nix taugt.
Das ist übrigens ein interessanter Punkt, weil es da seit zig Jahren Gerichtsverfahren gibt, bei Oracle und Java. Ja, Java ist nämlich eigentlich ein vergleichsweise offener Standard. Aber als dann Android kam und das nachimplementiert hat und gesagt hat, okay, wir nennen es jetzt nicht Java, sondern wie war das, Dalvik? Da hat halt Oracle gesagt, ja, das sind immer noch so Apis und darauf beanspruchen wir Copyright. Und das ist genau der zentrale kriegsschauplatz für diese ganzen Cloud-Login-Dienste. Ob jetzt der Hersteller sagen kann, sagen wir mal, morgen könnt ihr an Microsoft kommen und sagen, ich implementiere jetzt die ganzen Amazon-Dinger nach. Ja, und dann kann sie...
Aber ja, prinzipiell.
Ja, also theoretisch, ne? In der Praxis haben sie eh praktisch alle von den Apis auch irgendwie als separaten Login-Dienst, der dann aber subtil anders ist, damit du nicht von ihnen wegmigrieren kannst. So, aber eigentlich wäre das ja ein denkbares Geschäftsmodell, dass man sagt, okay, deine Amazon-App läuft auch direkt bei uns, unmodifiziert. So, und da warten im Moment alle immer noch dieses Verfahren ab, was im Moment immer noch offen ist, wenn ich das jetzt nicht übersehen habe. Und das ist eigentlich...
Es gibt ja auch so Open-AWS-Projekte, die halt versuchen, halt Teile der Amazon-App in der Open-Nacht zu implementieren und so.
Ja, das ist aber alles scheiße.
Ja klar, ich meine, das ist halt nur für die stellt sich natürlich auch die Frage, wie viele Ressourcen stecken sie da rein, bevor sie wissen, ob Amazon die Appys halt copyrighten kann.
Ja, aber das ist also tatsächlich das wichtigste Gerichtsverfahren im Moment, würde ich sagen, für die IT-Industrie. Ob der Supreme Court findet, dass man Appys copyrighten kann oder nicht. Weil dann ist ganz Ende mit allen Versuchen gegen Lock-In vorzugehen.
Das Spannende, was ich hier dabei immer wieder beobachte, ist, dass diese Abhängigkeit von diesen Appys hat ja häufig auch den Grund, dass sie extrem vereinfachen. Also wenn du halt irgendwie so die Amazon Machine Learning Appys anguckst, so was die da so an Service offerieren, ist halt schon geil. Also da kannst du halt irgendwie Textdokumente reinschmeißen und dann kommt da halt irgendwie so ein structure-baum raus, der dir halt irgendwie den Text sortiert. Du kannst da Video reinschmeißen und dann kriegst du halt irgendwie da so deine Gesichtserkennung, deine Videos, also deine Gesichtsschnipsel rausmarkiert und kannst die direkt dann ins Face-Matching-Pipen und so.
Ultra-High-Level.
Ja, und du kannst irgendwie so da irgendwie dann dein Call Center ranhängen, also wirklich so anschließen, im Sinne von Plak, mit irgendwie einfach nur eine Verbindung rüberlegen und dann fallen dir halt alle deine Anrufe in deinem Call Center als so nicht ganz geiler, aber okay Transcription raus. So gibts halt alles so fertig so und du zahlst dann halt pro, keine Ahnung, transkribierte Stunde irgendwie 1,40 Dollar oder so. Also es ist halt so, als wenn du halt irgendwie so. Und die bieten ja halt auch so alle Möchenservice an. Neulich, was hab ich euch entdeckt? Amazon Ground Station.
Jaja, dieses Satelliten-Ding.
Das heißt, du kannst halt, die haben halt einfach auf alle ihre Data Center halt irgendwie, die halbwegs günstig gelegen sind, halt irgendwie so steuerbare Satzschüsseln angebaut. Und dann kannst du auch hinge- sagen, ich würde gerne mit meinem Satelliten reden. Welches Amazon Data Center ist denn gerade in der Nähe? Und dann buchst du dir halt Zeit auf diese Antenne und kannst halt mit deinem Satelliten reden und pippst unten gleich deine Daten direkt irgendwie in deine Amazon Cloud. Und das ist natürlich dann halt so. Also am Anfang ist es halt viel günstiger als deine eigene Hardware. Nein, das ist halt einfach, weil du hast halt keine Investmentkosten. Du zahlst halt pro Stunde.
Und am Anfang hast du auch wenig Last auf deinem System.
genau. Aber wenn du dann halt anfängst, tatsächlich so mal so Amazon Services mal so richtig zu benutzen. Also da halt irgendwie dieses Wir wollen jetzt mal Cloud uns skalieren und wir brauchen jetzt mal wirklich irgendwie 1000 Instanzen.
Ja, besonders wenn du so Lambda genommen hast. Das ist richtig scheiße teuer.
Dann wird es halt richtig teuer.
Also ist ja auch klar. Ich mein, Amazon hat ja das Investment. Ist doch klar, dass das nicht billiger ist, als wenn du selber machst. Ja, bloß die haben, die müssen ja auch die Hardware kaufen. Ist ja nicht so, dass sie da kostenlos rumsteht.
Bloß der Punkt ist halt, was dann passiert ist. Also ich hab jetzt bei so ein paar Startups beobachtet. Die haben halt angefangen auf AWS, weil halt erst mal kein Initial Investment, das spart halt erst mal Kapital. Und dann waren ein paar von denen wirklich erfolgreich.
Na schon Initial Investment. Du musst ja die Software erst mal geschrieben haben.
Ja, du hast es so fehl geschrieben. Okay, aber du brauchst halt keine, musst halt keine Hardware kaufen. Du musst halt irgendwie so ganz viele Sachen nicht machen. Du musst auch ganz viel Software nicht entwickeln, weil Amazon es schon für dich getan hat. Und dann werden die erfolgreich und überweisen sechsstellige Beträge im Monat an Amazon. Ja, so für irgendwie Cloud Services, wo du entspannt von der Code, die du im Heimjahr da hinschiebst, und dir problemlosen Datacenter hinstellen kannst und irgendwie die Rechner da reinschieben kannst, die du brauchst.
Es gab mehrere High-Profile-Versuche, sich da raus zu extrahieren, die fast alle in die Hose gehen.
Die können es halt mit dem raus extrahieren nicht, weil sie sich halt wirklich über die API so dermaßen dependent gemacht haben auf diese Amazons. Auch die funktionieren halt auch gut. Na, also ist halt so klar mit allem.
Gut genug, nennen wir es so.
Gut genug, so dass du halt irgendwie sagen kannst, okay, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie die replacen wollen würde mit Open Source Software oder mit Produkten von irgendjemand anders, ist mein Risiko, dass es vielschräg barbarisch groß oder dass mein Service schlechter wird. Einfach nur weil du halt auf diese API zu programmiert hast. Dagegen ist es wie was früher Microsoft mit Windungs gemacht hat, ja eigentlich Stickenship.
Ja, also das lustige ist ja, du kannst ja, es gab ja diese Skandalen oder das haben wir Skandalen, wo sich Leute aufgeregt haben, die ihre Produkte über Amazon verkauft haben. Und dann gab es irgendwie ein paar Wochen später ein Amazon eigenes Label, was das selbe Produkt in grün irgendwie als China nachbaut. genau, Amazon Basics verkauft es dann halt mit so nahe Null Marge, weil also Amazon benutzt sozusagen dich als Risikoträger, um zu sehen, was es sich nachzubauen lohnt. So und das haben wir bisher in der Cloud noch nicht so gesehen, ist jedenfalls mein Eindruck, oder? Dass sie sagen, okay, diese Mittel wäre, die machen wir jetzt auch mal. Also man sieht, man sieht eine kombinatorische Explosion an Diensten, die AWS anbietet.
Ja, es sind aber eher Sachen, die sie selber für ihren eigenen Kram entwickelt haben. Also ganz viel von dem Maschinenzeug sind halt eigentlich so Komponenten, die eigentlich in Alexa drin sind.
Ja und auch traditionelle Datenbank-Scheiße und so.
Klar, ja. Also okay, aber die Standout. Ja gut, aber die finde ich uninteressanter. Also aber das ist halt so der, klar, das passiert halt, aber das haben die anderen ja auch, aber.
Na ja, aber das geht mir mit Security genauso, dass ich sage, okay, also die Security-Vorfälle gegen Firmen, die irgendwie einen seit zwei Jahren patchbaren Bug geohnt werden, die interessieren mich halt auch nicht. Ja, weil ich sage, ey, weißt du, wenn du es nicht schaffst, einen Patch, der frei runterladbar im Internet ist, bei dir auszurollen, warum soll ich mir dann überhaupt anhören, wie scheiße es dir geht? Ja, das ist ja echt selber zugefügt. Das ist wie, wenn deine Öllampe im Auto bläht oder Bremse warten und du gehst nicht zur Werkstatt. Da habe ich dann auch keinen Mitleid. Da denke ich mir, okay, das ist dann halt Darwin. Aber so ist es halt nicht. Sondern im Effekt werden die Kosten eben an die Gesellschaft externalisiert. Wir haben jetzt halt alle so eine Art Wetterherangehensweise. Security Bugs passieren halt und du guckst halt nur noch, ja, ist es heute mehr oder weniger?
genau, wir betrachten sie halt wie eine Naturgewalt.
Passiert halt. Und nicht nur von der Betrachtung her, sondern auch von der Reaktion her. Das ist ein Trend, den ich heute eigentlich mal ansprechen wollte, der mir in letzter Zeit vermehrt auffällt, dass die Leute, es gab früher diesen Joke, dass man gesagt hat, der Updater ist fertig, wir schippen. Ja, den Rest können wir im Feld nachpatchen. Und heute ist es so, dass man sagt, der Updater geht und wir haben laufende Telemetrie. Dann können wir im Feld irgendwie nachpatchen und debaggen. Und vorher Qualitätssicherung sparen wir uns. Das heißt, nicht nur betrachten wir sozusagen die einkommenden Hacks als Wetterphänomen, sondern auch unsere Vorbereitung ist wie beim Wetter, dass wir schön Wetterstationen aufstellen und Daten rein kriegen und dann gucken, so aus welcher Windrichtung kommt denn heute der Hagel? So, aber niemand hat versucht, vorher irgendwie die Dächer abzudichten, sondern der gesamte Aufwand geht in das Aufstellen von irgendwelchen Wetterstationen, also so in der Analogie, in der Software jedenfalls. Man sieht, dass die Ausgaben dafür, architekturell stabile und belastbare Software herzustellen, sehr viel geringer sind als die Ausgaben in so Nachsorge.
Nicht mal Nachsorge. Ich meine, wenn ich mir angucke, ich gucke ja immer gerne.
Nachsorge ist nicht das richtige Wort.
Wenn ich so Office starte, Microsoft Office, wie viel Verbindung da aufbauen muss. Und vor allen Dingen wohin. Also das ist halt irgendwie quasi so, ich glaube, meine letzte Zählung war 36 oder 37 verschiedene Server, inklusive Skype und irgendwelches Zeug in China.
Und wo ich so denke, so was, was nach Skype gehört jetzt auch Microsoft.
Ich weiß, Microsoft gehört, aber ich habe kein Skype installiert.
Ja, denkst du, denkst du. Link heißt jetzt Skype for Business ist daher. Es ist zwar immer noch ein Ansatz, aber egal.
Anyway, also jedenfalls, was da halt passiert an dieser sogenannten Telemetrie ist halt einfach in so einer Weise explodiert, dass ich mir, also kann ich nur so Theorien dazu entwickeln, wieso es dazu kommt. So eine Theorie ist, da sind halt keine Ahnung, 20 verschiedene Teams, die in diesem Gesamtprodukt entwickelt haben und jedes von denen halt irgendwie seine eigene Telemetrievorstellungen, will halt irgendwie wissen, ob sein Teil jetzt irgendwie noch funktioniert.
Nee, das kann ich dir tatsächlich aus eigener Beobachtung erklären, wie es dazu gekommen ist.
Nämlich?
Ja, das ging nämlich so los, dass man gesagt hat, okay, wir haben hier unsere Software, was ist denn, wenn wir Bugs haben? Dann hat man Bug-Tracker eingerichtet und dann hat man gemerkt, okay, da kommen immer mehr Bugs rein. Die sollten wir mal fixen. Dann fängst du an deine Bugs zu fixen und dann stellst du fest, es kommen aber mehr Bugs rein, als du rausfickst. Okay, dann sagst du, okay, den müssen wir priorisieren. Jetzt priorisierst du die Bugs anhand von, wie schlimm wäre denn das, wenn jemand darüber geohnt wird? Dann fixst du die Bugs zuerst und es ergibt eine, was ich gerne als Bugswelle bezeichne, so wie eine Bugwelle beim Schiff, schiebst du so eine immer größer werdende Menge an Bugs vor dir her. Und die aktuelle Iteration ist, dass man sagt, du guckst nicht mehr, du fixst nicht mehr alle Bugs, die schlimm werden, wenn sie exploited werden, sondern du benutzt Telemetrie, um rauszufinden, welche tatsächlich exploited werden. Und die fixst du. Das heißt, das ist sozusagen die Nachiteration davon, dass wir mit dem Bug-Fix nicht hinterherkommen. Und wir investieren lieber in so Metabullshit, als dass wir mehr Leute einstellen, die Bugs fixen.
Okay, das erklärt immer noch nicht, warum man sich irgendwie zu 36 verschiedenen Servern connecten.
Na, weil es alles eigene Teams sind.
Okay, also der Teil der Theorie stimmt.
Ja, ja.
Okay. Und aber dann die Annahme, dass man erkennt, über welche Komponente man gerade exploitet, wurde es doch irgendwie auch Quatsch, oder?
Ja, natürlich. Ich meine, du siehst, das ist eine Illusion. Aber hör mal, wenn du anfängst, nicht alle Bugs zu fixen, über die Leute schlimm geohnt werden können, dann müssen wir über den Rest eigentlich gar nicht mehr reden. Also, worüber ich mich ja seit mehreren Jahren aufrege, ist ein Konzept namens Threat Intelligence, was für viel Geld verkauft wird. Und da kriegst du dann so ein Feed und da wird dir gesagt, heute kommen Angriffe von dieser IP aus Russland. Ja, und dann gehen die Leute zu ihren Firewalls und machen die IP aus. Und dann denkst du so, was tut ihr denn da? Ja, wir haben das vor vielen Jahren zum ersten Mal beim Kongress beobachten können, dass plötzlich alle möglichen Webseiten aus dem Kongressnetz nicht mehr gingen. Du änderst dich bestimmt, weil irgendwie im Vorjahr irgendjemand irgendwie Presse wirksam gehackt wurde aus dem Kongressnetz. Haben die dann alle angefangen, halt das Kongressnetz zu bannen in ihren Firewalls. Ja, als wenn das irgendwie ihre Probleme behebt.
Na, für den Moment vielleicht schon so, ne?
Ja, aber das ist genau, worauf ich hinaus will. Wir haben halt verschiedene Sichten auf dasselbe Problem. Wir haben auf der einen Seite die Sicht von mir als Techniker. Ich sage, hör mal, du hast hier einen haufen Scheiße, der muss mal gefixt werden. Ohne du hast dann die Sicht des Managers, der sagt, okay, wir haben hier diese Angriffe. Die sollten möglichst wenig Erfolg haben. Ja, aber dem Manager ist letztendlich wurscht, ob die irgendwie deswegen nicht mehr angreifen, weil der da drüben noch leichter angreifbar ist. Deswegen ist eine häufig vertretene Theorie. Wir müssen ja nicht sicher sein. Wir müssen nur muss nur teurer sein, uns zu exploiten als die anderen. Und das ist eine These, die Microsoft lange Jahre vertrieben hat. Und ich dachte mal, Leute, das funktioniert doch nicht offensichtlich. Hat es auch nicht. Aber inzwischen, so nach so 15, 20 Jahren, ist es so, dass inzwischen Apple ein deutlich stärkeres Ziel ist als früher. Obwohl der Marktanteil eigentlich nicht deutlich zugenommen hat. Und ich glaube, vielleicht haben sie doch recht gehabt, befürchte ich gerade. Dass sie gesagt haben, so rein wirtschaftlich zu argumentieren und zu sagen, okay, pass auf, wir müssen, das muss hier nicht sicher sein. Aber es muss billiger sein. So vom Preis-Leistungs-Verhältnis für den Angreifer muss es sich mehr lohnen, Apple anzugreifen als uns.
Naja, weil das liegt aber eher am Leistungsverhältnis, weil irgendwie Apple-User in der Regel mehr Geld haben.
Ja, aber es gibt halt auch weniger davon. Aber es gibt halt weniger davon. Das heißt, du hast so einen Hebel da drin, ne?
Also meine Theorie ist ja, dass wir da halt einfach so die ökonomische Spaltung der Gesellschaft sehen. Und dass halt irgendwie sich die, wenn du halt irgendwie als Angreifer sagst, okay, du willst halt irgendwie mindestens irgendwie 100.000 Euro im Monat machen, dann ist es halt sinnvoller da hinzugehen zu den Leuten, die nicht nur 10.000 Euro im Jahr verdienen. Ja.
Also Apple statt Android sagst du.
Wo gut die Leute Pixelphone sind ja genauso teuer, insofern ist es egal.
Ja, das ist übrigens aber eine Frage, bei der ich auch gerne mal nachdenken würde, ja. Denn mein Eindruck ist, also ich erinnere mich noch, in den 90er Jahren war Toyota plötzlich sehr erfolgreich. Und die Zeitungen haben dann Berichte gedruckt und haben gesagt, ja, das liegt daran, dass Toyota eine Qualitätsoffensive gefahren hat. Ja, und dann gab es so mehrere mystifizierende Berichte, was die alles für Voodoo-Handlungen da machen. Und der Westen hat dann auch angefangen, in Qualität zu investieren. Und das hat alle Produkte teurer gemacht. Ja, und ich glaube, wir erleben gerade die Gegenbewegung. Also ein paar der Stichwörter waren zum Beispiel so was wie Zero Defect oder Six Sigma oder irgendwie die Excellence irgendwas, Technical, irgendwas, Excellence. Also es gab da mehrere so Buzzwords und die sind heute aber alle weg. Ja, oder so Five Nines ist so eine Sache, die hört man noch gelegentlich bei Netzwerkkram, so dass man sagt, irgendwie die Ausfallwahrscheinlichkeit muss so gering sein, ja, das ist irgendwie nur 0,0 irgendwas Prozent. So diese Art von Anforderungen ist einfach weg heutzutage, aber die Preise sind ja nicht gesunken, sondern eher im Gegenteil, die Smartphones sind eher teurer geworden. Und ich glaube, dass da so eine wirtschaftliche Überlegung dahintersteckt, dass man sagt, okay, Qualität kostet Geld, Lock-in ist billiger, wir machen jetzt mal die Qualität weg, wir sparen jetzt mal die Qualität und im Gegenzug bringen wir aber mehr Gerätegenerationen raus. So und dann ändert sich aber, wie viel Telefone du verkaufen musst, um mit der Marge noch denselben Gewinn zu machen.
Also meine ich, diese Five Sigma-Nummer ist ja damals von Motorola, ich weiß nicht, ob auf 100 oder zum ersten Mal im größeren Stil eingeführt worden, hab ich vergessen.
Na angeblich ist kommt es von Jack Welch, der GM-Typ, der ja, GM ist ja dann in die Pleite gegangen, so vielleicht war das der Grundverarbeitunger, der das Ding Sigma macht.
Na ja gut, ich meine, die haben halt, versucht damit halt, die Qualitätskontrolle bis zum Ende durchzuziehen. Also die Grundidee dabei ist ja zu sagen, wenn du eine Massenproduktion hast am Fließband und da kommen Geräte raus, die Defekte haben, dann gehst du jedem Einzelnen nach. Das heißt also, wenn du halt da eine Platine vom Band kommt, die halt irgendwie, wo der Kondensator schon drauf ist oder wo halt irgendwas nicht in Ordnung ist, jeder einzelne Bug wird gefixt.
Und zwar als Prozess, dass du guckst, wie verhindern wir, dass diese Art von Bug noch mal passiert?
genau, wie verhindern wir, dass es noch mal passiert? Wie sorgen wir dafür, dass halt irgendwie zukünftig ähnliche Bugs, die aus derselben Strukturklasse kommen, halt nicht noch mal auftreten und so weiter. Und tatsächlich war bei Motorola, die hatten halt massive Qualitätsprobleme zwischendurch. Und dann haben sie halt irgendwann, also wir reden jetzt noch von so 80s, also so lange her. Und dann haben sie halt irgendwie angefangen, das für ihre Funkgeräte spart und so einzuführen. Und deswegen sind diese Geräte halt so rock solid gewesen. Also so Motorola-Funkgeräte war halt so der Vollstandard. Quasi so das Funkgerät-Equivalent zu diesen, den alten Nokia-Telefon, die halt irgendwie also einfach so, kannst du als Flaschenöffner verwenden und ansonsten eigentlich fast auch nicht kaputt kriegen. So und dementsprechend teuer waren die halt aber auch. Und was dann halt passiert ist natürlich, dass halt irgendwie der Trick, dass man Qualitätssicherung bezahlbar bekommt, den haben halt die meisten Firmen nicht hinbekommen. Und dann ist halt so das jetzige Modell zu sagen, so man schludert halt genau so, dass man mindestens beim Test am Ende der Production Line den Großteil der defekten Geräte mitbekommt, also das sozusagen im Testing mitbekommt, um die dann auszusortieren. Und dann irgendwie sortiert man die nach Defektklassen und guckt dann halt so in die obersten 30 Prozent oder so, also die halt sozusagen das größte Volumen an Defekten ausmachen. Die Bugs fixt man und sorgt ansonsten nur dafür, dass man den Ausschuss nicht zum Kunden schickt. Das ist halt der momentane Modus Operandi, wie halt irgendwie ganz viel Produktion stattfindet.
genau wie bei den Bugs.
Ja, genau. Das ist halt so total äquivalent. Also man geht halt hin und sagt, man versucht halt, sich auf die Sachen zu konzentrieren, die besonders häufig auftreten und gut besonders schlimm natürlich auch noch, wenn es halt irgendwie blöd kommt. Aber am Ende ist es dann halt so ein, also man ist, erinnert mich so ein bisschen daran, wieso hatten wir denn dieses Gefühl, dass diese Nokia-Telefone alle so Rock-Solid sind. Die Software auf den Dingern war auch scheiße. Aber sie hatten damals genau das, was sie halt über das...
Bootete schnell.
Und zwar ohne, dass du es mitbekommen hast. Also diese Nokia-Telefone funktionieren ja auf der Software-Ebene so ein bisschen so ähnlich wie so Telco-Hardware. Die bootet auch nur schnell und die wird von Watch Dogs bewacht. Und auf diesem Telefon gab es auch mehrere Watch Dogs. Die haben halt gesehen, wenn irgendwie der Colonel weggecrashed ist oder irgendwie in das UI eingefroren ist. Und so die haben es halt einfach schnell gebootet. Und sie konnten halt so Teile von dem Ding booten, dass du dich nicht nochmal neu einbuchen musst. Weil die halt irgendwie quasi den State von dem Baseband, was halt mit dem Netzwerk geredet hat, haben die halt bewahrt, während sie da drüber den ganzen Kram rebooted haben und was sie mitbekommen hat. Meistens hat es halt rebooted, wenn du so eine Hosentasche hattest. Also die haben halt auch zum Beispiel so Sachen gemacht, wie wenn du halt irgendwas auf dem Keyboard gemacht hast und da drunter war schon irgendwas total schlimm, dann haben sie dein Input gecashed und haben dann erst gebootet, wenn du nicht hingeguckt hast. Also du wusst nicht, ob du hinguckst, aber so, dass du nicht gesehen hast. So haben dann halt Display Framebuffer eingefroren, da drunter gebootet und dann wieder weitergemacht. So ein Scheiß, ne?
Ich erinnere mich noch, als das der hauptvorwurf an die Chinesen war, dass die...
Dass man sieht, wenn es bootet.
Ne, ne, ne, ne. Davor zwei Kommentare. Erstens gibt es diese Apple-Geschichte, aber die andere Sache war, ich erinnere mich noch, dass man gesagt hat, okay, wenn du in China was herstellst, dann gehst du hin und dann machst du Qualitätssicherung und dann sagst du, ist scheiße. Und dann gibt es Verhandlungen und dann machen sie das so lange besser, bis du weggehst und danach geht es wieder runter. Ja, dass die... So, das war immer die Beschwerde des Westens am Chinesen, dass du dich nicht darauf verlassen kannst, wenn du einmal Qualität eingependelt hast, dass es dann dabei bleibt, sondern die haben dann halt angefangen und haben es halt billiger gemacht und haben den Profit eingestrichen. Ja, so. Und das machen wir jetzt genauso. Und die andere Anekdote, die mir da spontan einfällt, ist als Apple von US9 wegwollte. Und sie haben verschiedene Leute gefragt, unter anderem BOS und Next Step, haben gefragt, wie schnell bootet denn euer Scheiß? Das war die Nummer eins Anforderung, das muss schnell booten. Und Next Step hat gesagt, wissen wir nicht mehr, schon so lange her. Und das hat gewonnen, dachte ich eigentlich damals. Aber ja, offensichtlich nicht. So, das ist zwar offensichtlich besser, wenn es nicht booten muss, aber es ist eben nicht so, dass sich das dann durchsetzt, sondern du hast dann halt diesen Effekt, dass es dann eben doch immer wieder scheiße wird. Und heute ist es ja so, du kriegst gar nicht mehr mit, wie viel Uptime dein System erreicht, weil du halt irgendwie alle Nase lang eine neue Version reinpatchen musst.
Also mein System hat hier eine Uptime von mittlerweile 29 Tagen, was halt heißt irgendwie...
Das ist doch gar nichts. Früher haben wir hunderte von Tagen.
Nee, aber der letzte Mal ist halt nach dem letzten Security-Update.
Naja, genau. Aber das heißt...
Die 30 Tage sind bald wieder rum.
Ja, aber das heißt, es gibt halt überhaupt keinen Anreiz für die, dafür zu sorgen, dass das ordentlich ist. Weil so lange lebt es eh nicht. Das ist wie in Tschernobyl. Es gab doch in Tschernobyl diese Geschichte, dass alle dachten, okay, da ist jetzt irgendwie tote Erde. Nix, da ist ganz viel, die ganzen Tierarten, die kürzer leben als so ein Krebs braucht, um ein Tier umzubringen, den geht's super, ja? So. Und so ist das mit Software halt auch. Wir bauen jetzt eben Software, die nicht lang genug lebt, um von dem Krebs umgebracht zu werden. Und liefern jetzt halt metastasierte Krebstellen aus.
Das muss man tatsächlich dem OSX zugutehalten. Wenn man es halt nicht patcht, dann läuft es auch hunderte von Tagen einfach durch. Also es geht schon. Also das Next Step darunter ist schon okay. Kann man schon sagen. Also der Körner ist schon okay. Kräscht tatsächlich wirklich.
Ich sag da mal nix zu.
Extrem selten. Also Chrome kräscht häufiger als der Körner. Jaja, also...
Eigentlich wollten wir jetzt zu defensiver Software kommen. Ja, also man sieht halt, die Idee, dass man Exploits kauft, ist eine Sache, die vom Staat vor allem gemacht wird, von irgendwelchen Behörden. Ja, und dem Militär, die glauben, wenn sie jetzt irgendwie andere Leute schnell genug angreifen, dann kommen die nicht mehr dazu, uns anzugreifen oder so. Was natürlich Quatsch ist. Und die, was Firmen machen und Organisationen und Einzelpersonen, ist eher defensiver Sicherheit. Und das ist aber inzwischen ein so breiter Bereich, dass es da lohnt, auch noch mal zu differenzieren. Also wir haben... Die offensichtliche Idee wäre, dass man einfach bessere Software entwickelt. Ich sag das jetzt mal, als wenn es kein Problem wäre. Dass man sich irgendwie Methoden überlegt, packfreie Software zu schreiben. Das wird aber so gut wie nicht gemacht. Die nächste Annäherung wäre, dass man mit Testing guckt, dass sie dann wenigstens zuverlässig hochkommt und irgendwie keine Chordumps hinterlässt, beim Durchstarten und so. Also funktionale Tests, was aber nicht dasselbe ist, wie ordentliche Software zu schreiben. Ja, sondern das ist halt, ich erinnere mich manchmal auch mit grauen an unseren Alternativlos-Podcast über Atomkraftwerke, der jetzt schon echt viele Jahre her ist. Wo uns der Herr Seiler damals erklärt hat, wie so ein Atomkraftwerk eigentlich funktioniert und dass es alles indirekte Messungen sind, weil du überhaupt keinen Sensor natürlich in diese Temperaturen reinbringen kannst. Und so ähnlich ist das hier auch. Wir machen so indirekte, indirekte Verwässerungsverfahren, die aber das eigentliche Problem gar nicht lösen.
Also bist du denn sicher, dass diese ganze Telemetriequatsch, dass der wirklich nur für Security ist?
Nein, aber damit wird es begründet. Weil ich meine, so inzwischen ist das ein Geschäftsmodell, aber das war es nicht von Anfang an.
Also weil ich so die Menge an Daten, die da abfließt, kann einfach nicht kring sein. Also wenn man sich so anguckt, wie halt irgendwie Microsoft dieses Zeug betreibt, also in Office 360 zum Beispiel, wenn du da irgendwie nicht alles ausknipsst, was du ausknipsen kannst, dann kannst du eigentlich auch gleich Google Docs nehmen und den Kram irgendwie direkt auf deren Cloud-Servern editieren, weil das nimmt sich dann auch nicht mehr viel so.
Ja, na es gab doch hier, es gab hier jetzt jahrelang Berichte über Windows 10 von Leuten, die versucht haben, alles auszuschalten und es ging schlicht nicht. Konntest du nicht ausschalten. Und selbst Open Source-Software ist nicht gefällt. Also ich bin ja ein Firefox-Benutzer und ärgere mich da seit Jahren darüber, dass du im Grunde einmal pro Monat die Settings durchgehen musst, ob irgendwas dazu gekommen ist.
Haben sich große Vorwürfe bei Facebook gemacht.
Das ist wirklich zum Kotzen. Ja, aber das ist ein aktueller Trend und weißt du, es gibt ja häufig so, ich will mal sagen, Marketing-Aussagen, so von wegen irgendwie Blockchain wird uns retten oder eben Big Data ist der Schatz der Zukunft, dann sind das Öl. Da glauben die wirklich dran. Ja, die sagen auch Internet ist billig. Ja, und das ist halt richtig doll Scheiße, wenn du dann mal in einem Land bist, wo Internet eben nicht irgendwie breitband und billig ist, dann kriegst du nämlich mit.
Oder es gerade halt noch mal down ist.
Oder es down ist, ja. Oder in China zum Beispiel, das fand ich sehr witzig, hab ich glaube schon mal erzählt, hat mein Android-Telefon die ganze Zeit gezeigt, ich hätte kein Internet, obwohl ich natürlich Internet hatte, weil der das getestet hat.
Weil der Ping-Server nicht ging.
genau, weil er das getestet hat, indem er auf irgendeinen Google-Service zugegriffen hat und Google-Services sind halt blockiert aus China. Und das merkst du halt in solchen Gelegenheiten. Und wenn du auf die Mobilfunkrechnung guckst, ohne irgendwelche Interaktionen mit dem Telefon gemacht zu haben, wie viel Daten du da verbrätst für nichts und keiner sagt dir, wer es war. Also diese Telemetrie hat, glaube ich, angefangen als Security, aber inzwischen ist das natürlich ein...
Ein Schnorcheln.
Ist halt, ja, naja, Storage ist halt billig. Das ist übrigens auch so eine Sache, wo Amazon preistreiber war. Denn du telemetrierst ja nicht in dein, in dein eigenes Rechenzentrum, sondern in irgendeinem S3 Storage. Und Amazon bietet da relativ günstige Preise für Daten, auf die du nicht ständig zugreifst. Und die meiste Telemetrie ist so, dass einfach auf Halde irgendwo hin gespeichert wird.
Und sie bieten dir halt die Analyse-Services für dahinter an. Hier haben wir diese ganzen Machine Learning-Services, die dann halt für dich die Lockfiles da durchrödeln, um dir zu sagen, welche Bugs jetzt irgendwie die sind, die du dir vielleicht mal kümmern musst.
Ja, aber ich denk mir immer, die Zeit, die du verlierst beim Analyse-Services der Telemetrie, da hättest du die Hälfte deiner Bugs fixen können.
Klar.
Das ist totaler Scheiß. Aber ich wollte nur sagen, es gibt da so ein Spektrum aus Sachen, was man in der defensiven Security macht. Das Beste wäre, wenn man die Software einfach sicherer macht, aber da geht die Kohle nicht hin. Dann gibt es halt Testing, ist dir nicht Funktionalität überhaupt da? Und dann gibt es auch so reaktives Testing in Sachen Sicherheit. Das ist dann Code Audit. Das ist, was ich beruflich mache, dass ich mir halt den Code von so der Software angucke und nach Bugs suche. Aber es ist halt auch reaktiv. Ja, eigentlich wäre es ja besser, wenn wir eine Methode hätten, mit der wir Software so konstruieren können, dass ein Audit nicht nötig ist. Aber da forscht irgendwie niemand. Selbst das BSI, dem ich sehr zugute halte, dass sie überhaupt Projekte gemacht haben, als eine der ganz wenigen Institutionen weltweit, um mal Open Source Software sicherer zu machen. Selbst die haben praktisch ausschließlich, soweit ich weiß, auf Audits gesetzt, was ein guter Anfang ist. Ich will nicht gegen Audits argumentieren.
Du lebst da schließlich davon.
Klar, das wird mir hoffentlich die Rente bezahlen. Aber nein, die Rente bezahlt mir Stack Overflow. Vielen Dank an der Stelle an Stack Overflow. Können wir auch noch mal...
Ja, wo wir grad bei Stack Overflow sind, hatte da irgendwie die Tage eine interessante Begegnung mit jemand, der auch für die Offensivecon irgendwie in der Stadt war und da sich auch sehr zu hause fühlt, also auf der offensiven Seite und Expertspawn und verkaufen.
Ist auch total geil. Du wirst da umgauend. Du kriegst irgendwie alle Drogen, die du willst auf so einer Offensivecon. Wenn du irgendwie jemand bist, der regelmäßig Exploits raushaut, dann kriegst du alles, was du willst. Das ist ein tolles Leben, aber...
Also ich weiß nicht genau, ob der... Ich glaube, der verkauft, glaube ich, nicht, sondern der macht halt mehr so... Der hat halt so mehr so diesen, also sagen wir mal, etwas nihilisterischen Ansatz. Und der meinte halt dann irgendwann so zwischendurch, so irgendwie, ja, wenn er Langeweile hat... Also der hat so ein richtiger Black Hat. Und dann meinte halt dann so, ja, wenn er Langeweile hat, dann hilft er jetzt Leuten auf Stack Overflow.
Sorgt für Nachwuchs.
Nein, was heißt Nachwuchs?
An Sicherheitslücken, die ausgelöst werden.
genau. So er meinte halt so der andere NSC-Contest. Also das, wo man halt irgendwie Programme schreibt, bei denen irgendwie die bechdauer nicht sichtbar ist. Der wäre doch auf Stack Overflow, also diese Webseite, wo man irgendwie nach Fragen stellt und dann Kurz-Nippels bekommt, sehr viel besser aufgehoben. Und außerdem wäre es auch echt effizienter, weil dann muss man nicht drauf warten, dass die Leute selber blöde Ideen haben, sondern kann ihnen schon dabei helfen.
Aber Stack Overflow ist schon...
Nur konsequent, finde ich so.
Ja, aber Stack Overflow braucht keine Hilfe an der Stelle, muss man leider sagen. Die haben sich kaputt gamifiziert. Ja, das ist halt die Währung, in der man da bezahlt wird, dafür, dass man anderen hilft, sind halt so Internetgummipunkte. Und die kriegt man, wenn der Typ, der die Frage gestellt hat, sagt, oh, das war eine gute Antwort. So, aber der weiß ja per Definition nicht, welche Antwort gut ist und welche nicht. Der kann nur sehen, funktioniert das oder nicht. Ja, wenn er sich da eine Sicherheitslücke einfängt, dann merkt er das ja nicht. Oder jedenfalls nicht sofort. Das heißt, das Anreizsystem...
Das wird er nie wieder zusammenkriegen, dass die Sicherheitslücke dann... Und vor allen Dingen unterstellt er halt jemand, der ihm auf Stackoverflow geholfen hat, und da stellt er ja nicht, dass der das böswillig macht.
Ja, muss er ja auch, wie gesagt, gar nicht. Also, ich meine, das ist natürlich noch mal eine Steigerung, aber Stackoverflow ist so eine destruktive... Das wird mir die Rente bezahlen. Denn das Anreizsystem ist halt nicht eine gute, wohl durchdachte, ordentliche, treffende Antwort zu geben, sondern das Anreizsystem ist, schnell eine Antwort zu machen, die gut aussieht. Und das hat dazu geführt, dass es so eine Art Wettrennen darum gab, wer die besten textbausteine hat. Und wer zuerst antwortet, kriegt halt den Internetpunkt. Und da ist dann halt nicht Qualität gefragt, sondern da ist so viel Bullshit unterwegs. Also inzwischen, wenn ich ein Audit mache, greppe ich immer nach Stackoverflow. Und das ist erstaunlich häufig, dass man da Kommentare findet. Im Sourcecode. Ja, und da steht dann, ja, das hab ich hier von Stackoverflow. Frage so und so URL. Und dann ich mir so, alles klar, vielen Dank.
Also ich meine, immerhin ist es eine ordentlich Dokumentarkultur.
Ja, das finde ich gut. Und da kann ich auch nur zu aufrufen, macht es auch, wenn ihr von Stackoverflow was kopiert. Und sei es nur zu eurer eigenen Exkulpation. Damit ihr sagen könnt, das hat euch jemand falsch empfohlen. Macht das weiter, das erfreut sich der Auditor, freuen sich alle. Ja, aber worauf ich eigentlich hinaus wollte, wir haben halt eine Menge Geld, was ausgegeben wird für Defensive Security und fast nichts davon ist so.
Für Offensive meinst du?
Nee, für Defensive.
Okay.
Also es wird eine Menge Geld investiert, aber halt praktisch nichts davon tatsächlich für Sachen, die die Sicherheit steigern, sondern alles so Metamaßnahmen. Also Threat Intelligence ist so der übelste Auswurf. Aber diesen Trend, dass man sagt, wir müssten hier Daten erheben, den gibt es schon lange. Ja, das hieß am Anfang, hieß das Log-Auswertung von der Firewall. Dann hieß es Intrusion Detection System. Dann hieß es Intrusion Prevention System. Dann hieß es, hat die Schlangenölindustrie, hat angefangen, irgendwelche Konsolen für ihre Endpoint Security anzubieten. Und da macht man Big Data drauf. Und dann gab es ein Sieben, das ist auch jetzt irgendwie ein Trend, der gerade wieder am abeben ist, ist mein Eindruck. Aber das sind alles so, das hilft ja alles überhaupt nicht gegen die gegen die Sicherheitslücken, sondern das die Idee ist, dass ich erkennen kann, wenn ich angegriffen wäre, werde. Und das ist halt so das Gegenteil dessen, was ich gern möchte. Also mein Ziel ist gern, dass ich, dass ich nachts ruhig schlafen kann, weil ich weiß irgendwie, da passiert halt nichts. Wer mich angreifen will, beißt sich gerade die Zähne aus. Das ist meine Zielvorstellung. Ja, ich hab nichts dagegen, dass man ein bisschen Telemetrie macht, wenn man das erreicht hat. Ja, aber es ist halt nicht so, sondern was ich beobachte, ist, dass die Leute erst Telemetrie machen und dann sich aber den Rest sparen.
Ich glaube, dass der diese Idee mit dem Telemetrie und dem Software telefoniert die ganze Zeit nach hause. Die ist ja so ein bisschen langsamer eskaliert. Das ist ja so der Punkt, dass wir das jetzt irgendwie, diese ganze Telemetriequatsch einen durchaus nicht insignifikanten Anteil des Traffics macht, den man halt auf so einem normal benutzten Usercomputer sieht, ist ja eigentlich erst in den letzten drei, vier Jahren passiert. So und vorher war es ja eher so, dass so diese nach hause telefonieren Sachen fing eher so an mit so License Verification Kram. Das war so der erste Schritt. Und dann hat man schon immer angefangen mit der License halt dann, die Systemkonfiguration zu übertragen. Also welche Betriebssystemsversion? Dann ging es weiter mit, was ist denn dann noch so für Software installiert? So also was ist denn das Environment so? Dann ging es irgendwie mit irgendwie Location weiter, wenn man die irgendwie ermitteln konnte.
Da gibt es aber auch eine technische Erklärung für. Du brauchst nämlich, um diese Art von hochvolumigen Echtzeitdaten verarbeiten zu können, Spezialdaten banken. Und die haben früher nur ganz wenige Firmen gebraucht, so jemand wie eine Telco fürs Billing. Und das war ein Spezialbranche-Teil, wo es dann auch Speziallösungen gab. Also ich erinnere mich zum Beispiel, dass ich mal von so einer, einer der ersten objektorientierten Datenbanken gehört habe, die speziell damit Werbung gemacht haben, dass sie so und so viele Billion Records pro Tag. genau. Ja, das war deren Sales-Page, dass sie gesagt haben, wir können mit so viel Bewegt-Daten umgehen. Und dass das heute praktisch für jeden verfügbar ist, liegt unter anderem daran, dass man es eben bei Amazon als Service mieten kann.
Stimmt, du kannst es.
Und es gibt wirklich ein Dutzend inzwischen so Spezial, irgendwie Streaming-Datenbanken ist so der Begriff. Und auch das Elasticsearch heute so bekannt und groß, das liegt unter anderem daran, dass viele Leute da ihre Logs reinpipen. überhaupt auch Seams sind ja auch so was.
Seams heißt Security, Incident and Event Management.
Nee, ich stehe glaube ich nicht für Incident. Also es ist jedenfalls so was wie ein zentraler Log-Server, wo man alle Log-Daten aus dem Unternehmen zusammenführt und dann Korrelationen versucht zu erkennen. Oder Muster zu erkennen und Alerts auszuhauen, das ist die Idee beim Seam. Und das sind auch Spezialdatenbanken, das macht man nicht einfach in der SQL-Datenbank.
Naja, und dann gibt es ja dieses ganze In-Memory-Database-Dingens, wo man dann möglichst viel High-Performance irgendwie...
Ja, das ist halt auch teuer, wenn du ein bisschen Volumen hast. Also ich will sagen, Amazon ist schuld.
Dann wissen wir schon mal irgendwie, der ist schuld, das ist schon mal gut.
Es hat aber, es gibt noch einen anderen Trend, der so ein bisschen verwandt ist, haben wir auch schon anklingen lassen, ja. Früher war das so, wenn die Software gepatcht werden musste, dann war die Software schlecht. Ja, das war so, du hast erkannt, dass die Software scheiße ist, daran, dass es ständig Patches gab.
genau, dass es ständig Patches gab, ja.
Und heute ist das Gegenteil der Fall. Da denkst du, die Software ist schlecht, wenn es nicht ständig Patches gibt. Ja, und das ist eigentlich eine Sache, da hätten die Leute auf die Barrikaden gehen müssen, finde ich. Tun sie aber nicht.
Na ja, gut, aber ich meine, Oracle hat ja lange versucht, irgendwie auf der Wir-sind-gute, wenn wir nicht ständig Patches haben, Logik zu beharren.
Ja, dann gab es aber so ein Quartal, Quartals-Patches mit irgendwie 500.
genau.
Das sieht halt auch nicht gut aus.
Sieht halt auch nicht so gut aus, oder so. Also, ich meine, eigentlich will man ja Software, die deswegen nicht gepatcht werden muss, weil es keine Notwendigkeit dafür gibt.
Das erkennst du halt nicht von außen, ne?
Aber selbst Open BSD patcht ja irgendwie wie die Hölle. Das ist jetzt auch nicht irgendwie so.
Das ist heutzutage, da hat sich echt der Blickwinkel um 180 Grad gedreht, dass man... Früher hat man gesagt, ey, dieses Chrome, das will ständig patchen, das ist doch scheiße. Und heute sagt man, ey, wo bleibt denn der Chrome-Patch?
Noch kein Chrome-Patch heute.
Ja, ey, auf Heise gibt es jetzt Berichte so, klicken Sie mal manuell auf Patchen bei Chrome, weil da gibt es jetzt irgendwie... Wo sind wir hier eigentlich, ja? In was für einer Dystopie leben wir hier eigentlich, dass wir ständig manuell am Bitte-Patch-Jetzt-klicken sind? Oder Patch-Tuesday bei Windows, da werden auch alle Leute nervös und klicken, gibt es denn jetzt so mein Update, wo ist denn mein Update? Ich brauche jetzt mein Update. Und dann sitzt du so, ey, das ist hier wie so ein Opium denn. Ich brauche jetzt meinen Fix.
Na gut, aber wenn du dir gerade bei Windows die Turnaround-Zeiten zwischen Patch-Release und Exploit-Availability anguckst, da sind wir ja schon signifikant unter 24 Stunden mittlerweile, so irgendwie bei den meisten Sachen.
Dann du immerhin gibt es bei Windows so ein bisschen Visibility, bei den anderen ja überhaupt nicht. Oracle sagt dir nicht, wann der Patch gemeldet wurde. Und Microsoft normalerweise auch nicht, aber Microsoft verbietet den Leuten, die den Patch gemeldet haben, nicht das zu sagen. Und deswegen gibt es da so ein bisschen Visibility.
Nee, aber selbst da ist es ja so, dass irgendwie, also nehmen wir mal an, irgendwie, Microsoft benimmt sich vorbildlich und irgendwie kriegt den Patch schnell durchgeprügelt, weil er wirklich kritisch ist. Gibt es ja tatsächlich.
Das geht dann auch recht schnell.
Dann ist ja trotzdem für die Windows-User der, also der sinnvolle Weg halt ja so extrem schnell wie möglich zu patchen, weil die Zeit von der Patch ist draußen, bis es gibt irgendwie verfügbare Exploits dafür, ist wie gesagt ja unter 24 Stunden gesunken bei irgendwie bei interessanten Sachen so. Heißt halt also, wenn du nicht innerhalb der ersten 24 Stunden gepatcht hast, bist du selber schuld. Dann bist du halt echt im Eimer so, oder?
Ja, ich hab, ich mach das ja gerne bei Vorträgen in letzter Zeit, dass ich sage so, wir patchen dann innerhalb von 24 Stunden seine Firma durch. Niemand.
Klar nicht.
überhaupt nicht. 24 Stunden ist so anhört. Ist Sci-Fi für die, die sind ja, wir haben, wir wollen ja jetzt demnächst unter zwei Monate die genau so, was? Ja, das ist ja komisch. Wir haben immer diese Emotet-Angriffe. Ich so ja, ja.
Na gut, ich meine, wenn du dir halt so eine typische Firma anguckst, das wollen die dann auch machen. Also ich meine, die haben da halt irgendwelche gammlige Randsoftware, die von der sie halt abhängen und wo sie halt nicht so genau wissen, ob die dann mit dem Patch funktioniert, dann müssen die halt erstmal testen so.
Oder du schmeißt halt diese scheiß Software raus. Ich würde das, wäre ja mein Ansatz zu sagen.
Ich meine, häufig genug ist es dann halt so Zeug, wo du halt irgendwie nicht einfach mal so machen kannst, wo du deine Firma komplett umkrempelst. Also ich meine, das ist dann halt...
Nee, aber guck mal, du kannst doch zumindest... Guck mal, wir haben es doch hier mit einem Markt, mit Angebot und Nachfrage zu tun. Und wer soll denn bitte den Druck aufbauen?
Na bloß nicht die Kunden. Wenn halt irgendwie deine Alternative ist, auf SAP zu migrieren, was für viele wirklich die Frage ist, weil die haben halt dann so Custom-Build irgendwie...
Ja, die meisten sind ja schon auf SAP.
Homebrew, irgendwie Software, die halt irgendwie das macht, was ein SAP halt macht. Und dann haben sie halt die Wahl zwischen, sie halten den Kram irgendwie am laufen oder sie begehen direkt Suizid, wenn sie SAP-Migration machen. Das ist jetzt aber zu böse. Wieso?
Nein, es gibt...
Also, ich meine, die Anzahl der Firmen, die in SAP-Migration überleben, ist nicht so groß.
Ja, aber das ist ja bei Design. Du führst ja nicht SAP ein, damit der deine Prozesse abbildet, sondern du führst SAP ein, um die Prozesse des Marktführers zu übernehmen, die in SAP abgebildet wurden.
Nein, nein. Du führst SAP ein, weil du möglichst in der Lage sein willst, Merchant-Acquisition-fähig zu sein. Das ist nicht so, das ist nicht so, dass irgendwie SAP wirklich die Prozesse des Marktführers abbildet, sondern nur die kompliziertesten und größten Prozesse, nicht die effizientesten.
Ja, wie gesagt, die des Marktführers.
Ja, also Marktführen ist dann halt so eine relative...
Ja, in Größe, nicht in Effizienz.
genau, das ist halt so, was halt heißt, wenn du halt mal in so große Firmen reinguckst.
Das ist so unfassbar, was da für Energie verbrannt wird.
Also ich meine, da hast du so Sachen wie...
Man darf ja ein CO2 einsparen könnte.
Wenn du dann mit denen redest, denkst du so, naja, also wie wär's denn so, mal so Zahlungstier 60 Tage, wäre doch mal eine gute Sache so, damit der eure Lieferanten... Die sind dazu nicht in der Lage. Also die können das einfach nicht, weil die Prozesse sind halt dann so kompliziert und glacial. Und dann denkst du, okay, aber ich meine, andere Leute kriegen es auch innerhalb von 24 Stunden.
Das wird ab jetzt noch schlimmer. Denn wenn du guckst, was im Moment als Digitalisierung läuft im Lande, ist, dass sie die Kosten für das Ausfüllen der überflüssigen Formulare ihrer beschissenen Prozesse outsourcen an ihre Dienstleister. Ja, wenn du bei irgendeinem Konzern gern auf der Liste der Zulieferer sein willst, dann geben die dir ein Weblogin bei irgendeinem ranzigen irgendwie Mittelwehr-Gammelscheiß und dann bist du da Wochen beschäftigt, irgendwie irgendwelche Scheißformulare auszufüllen und siehst aber nicht mal die Fehlermeldung. Die Fehlermeldung sieht irgendein Mitarbeiter von denen und der schickt dir dann eine Mail, die dir nicht weiterhilft. Also diese, das ist im Moment Digitalisierung. Outsourcen der Kosten für das Ausfüllen von Formularen und für das Umgehen mit unserer Gammel-Software wird outsourced an die, oder externalisiert, nicht outsourced, wird externalisiert an die Leute, die mit uns zusammenarbeiten wollen. Das heißt, es wird eher noch schlimmer ab jetzt.
Ja, also, und dann hast du, bei großen Konzernen hast du dann häufiger so externe Dienstleister, die für die die Lieferanten Rechnungsabwicklung machen. Und da passieren dann so Sachen so, also wo du sozusagen dann musst du...
Die auch in Kasse übernehmen, wenn du willst.
Nee, nee, da geht es halt darum, dass du willst Geld von einem Konzern haben. Als kleiner Dienstleister so, ne? Und dann wirst du dazu gezwungen, dich auf so einen blöden Portal zu registrieren, was halt von diesem Dienstleister für irgendwie diesen Konzern betrieben wird.
Der dann Sachen haben will, die er gar nicht zum Arbeiten braucht. Aber das war es in der Formulare, das haben wir halt auch nur gekauft. Da tragen sie ja mal 4711 ein, das ist nicht so wichtig. So, wat?
genau. So und dann geht es halt los, dass sie dann halt feststellen, oh ja, also diese Rechnungsnummer, die sie jetzt da gerne irgendwie bezahlt haben wollen würden, die kennen wir hier gerade noch nicht, weil das Rechnungsformat von dieser Abteilung da ist noch nicht angepasst auf das, was irgendwie unser Rechnungssystem haben will.
Das ist Digitalisierung im Jahre 2040.
So und dann hast du halt so Dinge wie, du sagst halt zu der Abteilung, naja, pff, also wissen sie, ich warte jetzt schon seit vier Monaten auf mein Geld, weil euer System noch nicht funktioniert. Ich stelle jetzt mal die Arbeit ein, bis halt irgendwie mein Geld da ist. Und sie können ja einfach mal dahingehen und sagen, wir beschleunigen mal das Zahlungsziel, damit irgendwie mein Geld rechtzeitig ankommt. Das ist ja durchaus gerade umfassend passiert, der hatte genau dieses Problem. Und dann geht dann halt die Fachabteilung hin und sagt so, naja, also wir würden halt eigentlich schon gerne, dass dieses Projekt hier langsam mal vorankommt, weil das ist halt security-kritisch. Na ging um Ordet.
Ja, wir können auch nichts dafür. Und dann, das ist ja das Problem. Und dann sagt, wir haben ein Mobile aufgebaut aus Leuten und keiner kann dafür, weil die alle gefangen sind in ihrem kleinen Privatgefängnis aus beschissener Software.
Und dann sagt die Fachabteilung zu einem einkauf hier so, naja, wir müssen jetzt hier mal, weil sonst brennt hier halt die Hütte so und brennt halt wirklich. Weil wir müssen dieses Projekt abschließen, weil es kritisch und plan und ins Hemd ist und so weiter und so fort. Und dann sagt der einkauf, ja, naja, also es gibt hier in der Software keine Funktion für Zahlungsziel auf weniger als 90 Tage setzen, weil das ist halt die Voreinstellung, die halt irgendwie vom Vorstand so beschlossen wurde.
Ja, wieso ist denn das dein Problem, frage ich mich dann.
genau, ist es ja nicht.
Ja, also ich denke mir, wir müssten einfach anfangen und sagen, okay, wenn ihr nicht sofort zahlt, gibt es keine Mahnung, sondern dann erwirke ich einen Titel und dann kommt der Gerichtsvollzieher. Weil anders wird es, glaube ich, nicht besser.
Das machst du halt natürlich nicht beim Großkonzern, weil du dann halt weißt, dass der einkauf dich dann halt blacklistet.
Ja, aber gerecht wär's.
Das ist halt das Problem so, ne?
Ja, also ich habe teilweise Situationen, da wollen die dann, ja, die Rechnung müssen sie selber einpflegen in unser System. So, sagen wir mal wirklich. Das entspricht aber nicht dem bürgerlichen Gesetzpunkt. Ihr ist meine Rechnung, ihr müsst nicht zahlen. Ja, nee, das ist aber nicht in unserem System.
Und weißt du, was der nächste Schritt sein wird? Der nächste Schritt wird sein, dass sich Dienstleister etablieren, die das für dich als Kleiner machen.
Jaja, genau, genau.
Und die sich dann irgendwie, nehmen sich dann fünf Prozent von deiner Rechnung und kümmern sich dann darum, diesen Scheiß mit den Großkonzernen abzusetzen.
Das ist so ein Kotzen, ja. Aber es schafft Arbeitsplätze, deswegen will die SPD das.
Ich meine, das ist halt, also, ich meine, so, also muss man mal klar sagen, so sieht Digitalisierung heutzutage halt aus. Also das ist halt das, was die unter Digitalisierung von Geschäftsprozessen verstehen.
Das ist die Externalisierung von Behaltungskosten.
Ich meine, das wird, also, ich bin mir 100% sicher, was jetzt passieren wird, ist, da werden sich Dienstleister etablieren, die sagen, okay, wir, zumindest bei den großen Konzernen, wo wir halt ein relativ geringes Risiko von forderungsausfall haben, für unbestrittene Rechnungen kaufen wir die Forderungen an und schlagen uns dann halt irgendwie mit…
Und zahlen dir das direkt aus?
Zahlen wir das direkt aus, minus fünf Prozent oder irgendwas, so irgendeinen Betracht, der halt irgendwie für dich noch gerade so verschmerzbar ist und kümmern uns dann darum, uns irgendwie mit diesem SAP direkt auseinanderzusetzen.
Ich glaube, wir haben gerade ein Geschäftsmodell entwickelt. Wollen wir mal schnell einen Start-up gründen?
Ich bin fast sicher, dass das schon gibt.
Ich hab noch nichts dergleichen gehört, aber ich stimme dir zu, dass das die Zukunft…
Eigentlich ist das doch vollkommen offensichtlich, ne?
Ja. Wollen wir das mal eben gründen?
Ja. Eigentlich ist das ein guter Plan. Okay, liebe Hörer, wir müssen den gerade mal Schluss machen. Wir haben gerade Wichtigeres zu tun. Wir könnten uns mit ein paar großzügigen Spenden davon abhalten. Ja, wahrscheinlich sollte man solche Sachen nicht erzählen, weil sonst macht es noch irgendjemand. Aber vielleicht eigentlich wäre es gut, wenn es jemand macht. So, ne?
Also, das ist wirklich zum heulen, dass man darüber nachdenkt, was denn jetzt schlimmer wäre. Weiter mit irgendwelchen, weißt du, wenn es alles SAP wäre, könnte man sich ja irgendwie, dann würde ich ja sogar sagen, okay, die Zeit investiere ich jetzt, mir einmal irgendwie anzulernen, wie man da seine scheiß Rechnung reinkippt. Aber bisher war das noch immer irgendwas anderes jeweils. Und eins schlimmer als die anderen. Und so, weißt du, fühlt sich dann an wie Pearl aus den 90ern teilweise. Und denkst du, oh, ja. Also unfassbar. Und ich denke mir immer, Samba, das muss euch doch auch wehtun. Ja, und dann rede ich mit den Leuten. Und ja, es tut ihnen weh. Aber sie haben alle ganz deutsch, aber das ist nicht ihre Entscheidung gewesen.
Aber sie haben eine hohe Schmerztoleranz entwickelt.
Nee, was sollen die denn machen? Die Geschäftsführung hat ihnen das da irgendwie reingesetzt? Was sollen die denn machen? Ja, das ist halt so. Wenn die Geschäftsführung auf einem Golfplatz wird, dass man da Kosten sparen kann, wenn man das externalisiert, dann...
Weil wahrscheinlich sparen sie sogar Kosten, weil sie halt irgendwie ihre gesamte einkaufsabteilung halt irgendwie halbieren konnten.
Ja, aber das ist ja auf Kosten der Lebenskraft, die sie ihren Mitarbeitern irgendwie absaugen und in die Hölle pumpen.
Die wird ja nur nach Stunden bezahlt, die Lebenskraft. Also ich vermute mal tatsächlich, dass irgendwie so diese jetzt länger ich drüber nachdenke, dass so ein quasi so ein Interface Provider, der irgendwie so Großkonzern auf normale Firmen adaptiert.
Ja, also könnte man sogar in beide Richtungen drüber nachdenken. Also dann nehme ich den Großkonzern, das verkaufst als, okay, wir lutschen, ihr braucht keine Integration kaufen, sondern wir nehmen davon, egal was ihr da habt. Und dann bist du am Ende sowas wie Datev. Und dann ist es nämlich sowas wie ein Argument für die Zusammenarbeit mit einer Firma, wenn sie mit dir zusammenarbeitet, weil dann musst du nur einmal.
genau, weil das halt irgendwie easy zu adaptieren.
Oh Scheiße, wir revolutionieren hier gerade die Digitalisierung in Deutschland.
Das wäre doch tatsächlich mal Digitalisierung. Also so richtig die Digitalisierung von Geschäftsprozessen mit. Wahrscheinlich könnte man endlos Förderung dafür abfassen, weil natürlich irgendwie kleine und mittelständische Unternehmen davon profitieren werden.
Ja, alle profitieren davon.
Alle profitieren davon. Wir müssen wirklich mal kurz mal hier ein Businessplan schreiben.
Es ist zum Heulen. Na gut, aber worauf wir eigentlich hinaus wollten ist, dass die Anreizsysteme alle so sind, dass es sich nicht lohnt, das gut zu machen. Ja, sondern die Anreizsysteme sind durchaus gelegt, die Schmerzen zu maximieren, die alle Leute haben. Deswegen geht es uns allen so scheiße.
Ich glaube, dass der Ansatz von diesen ganzen Projekten ist ja wahrscheinlich immer eigentlich ein guter. Ich glaube, die also das halt gemeint ist, der Herr von gut gemacht. Ich glaube, dass das tatsächlich so der das ganze Spiel darauf hinaus läuft, dass sie sich denken, so ja, unsere ganzen Rechnungsprozesse sind ja viel zu kompliziert. Und so müssen wir vereinheitlichen und digitalisieren harmonisieren, genau, und machen am besten gleich mit Digitalisierung so. Und dann kommt dabei dann so was raus, wo du dann halt irgendwie so ein Dienstleister hast, der dann sagt, okay, wir machen das für dich lieber Großkonzern. Und dann kommt, also dann sieht es aus, von der Flughöhe des Vorstands sieht es erstmal gut aus. Weil irgendwie, keine Ahnung, irgendwie alles ist jetzt harmonischer. Sie können jederzeit nachgucken, was irgendwie das Gesamtsalto ist, eingehörner ausgehend Rechnungsbestände haben, wie viele, wie sich das entwickelt hat, so genau wie viel Rechnungen irgendwie disputet werden. Und also diese ganzen Dinge kannst du halt alles schön nachgucken. Und dann, wenn du dann noch mal so rein zooms, dann zooms halt in so einen haufen blubbernder Scheiß. Also so und eine Güllegrube, genau so eine richtige Güllegrube. Ich frage mich, ob denen das klar ist. Ich muss mal rauskriegen, bin mir nicht mal so sicher. Bin mir echt nicht so sicher. Es kann gut sein, dass denen das nicht wirklich klar ist, weil das halt wirklich unterhalb der Flughöhe ist.
Nee, also meine Theorie dazu ist ja, dass die die die Management-Etage die Schreie hört und dass ein Indikator dafür ist, dass sie richtig richtig sind. Wenn sie keine Schreie hören würden, dann hätten sie Geld verschleudert. Das ist so eine der von Wirtschaftsoptimierern geratenen Indikatoren. Dass du sagst, wenn deine Leute zufrieden sind, dann hast du ihnen zu viel Geld investiert, um ihnen Arbeit abzunehmen. Das heißt, es muss irgendwie so ein grundrauschen an Unzufriedenheit geben, sonst hast du deine Sache nicht gut gemacht. Also ich glaube ja, wenn du an Management-Etagen was verkaufen willst, dann läuft das inzwischen über Apps. Wenn du eine App zeigen kannst, die dir irgendwie eine schöne Grafik malt von deinen Rechnungseingängen, dann kaufen die das, egal ob das mit ihrem Laden ansonsten kombinierbar ist oder nicht.
Ja, das ist halt diese Management-Cockpit-Nummer. Du kannst dein Unternehmen in einer App fliegen, während du auf dem Golfplatz stehst und über Digitalisierung redest.
Und alles aber total sicher wegen.
Na klar.
Bei uns ist immer sicher.
Und Machine Learning und Blockchain.
genau.
Ganz wichtig. Und dann in die App. Na gut.
Eigentlich wollten wir noch Präpper machen.
Erstmal wollten wir noch kurz die Fences Security fertigreden. Ja, genau. Also ich glaube ja, dass es schon so ein paar Anzeichen der Hoffnung gibt, weil an etlichen Stellen Leute verstanden haben, dass man jetzt mal langsam anfangen muss, Dinge besser zu machen. Aber die sind meistens halt dann eben auch eher so in den großen Konzernen, eher so bei Google oder bei Apple oder so oder vielleicht auch innerhalb von Microsoft und weniger in der Masse von Firmen, die halt so die ganzen kleinen Services bauen. Weil ich meine, alles, was halt irgendwie mit Web zu tun hat, bist du halt automatisch in diese Hölle von irgendwie automatisch gequetschten, dazugebauten Dependencies, wo du halt irgendwie...
Ja und nein. Also... Ich hab jetzt mehrfach beobachtet, dass so Web-Scheißfirmen, also jetzt auch nicht auf der kleinen Seite, im kleinen hast du recht, also diese ganze JavaScript-NPM-Notnachladekacke. Aber dass so Leute, die Web-Server-Services bauen, die jetzt nicht notbasiert sind, also es gibt so ein Not- und PHP sind, glaube ich, nicht zu retten. Aber es gab durchaus Ansätze, zum Beispiel besonders im Ruby-Umfeld war zum Beispiel ein starker Impuls für Test-Driven-Development, dass du immer erst einen Test machst. Und da sind teilweise Qualitätsvorsprünge erreicht worden, da könnten sich die anderen alle einen von abschneiden. Das Problem ist nur, dass es halt immer noch innerhalb von diesem Rails-Framework dann normalerweise läuft. Und das hat halt eine inhärente Komplexität, die im Grunde zu groß ist.
Die hat eigentlich nicht beherrschbar.
Die ist im Grunde nicht beherrschbar. Aber so der Ansatz, dass der Code, den wir schreiben, Test-Driven ist, das ist ein Riesending im Ruby-Umfeld gewesen. Und das hast du gesehen an der Qualität von den Ergebnissen. Also es ist nicht so, dass Web-Shit immer scheiße ist. Im Gegenteil ist es so, dass die Leute, die frisch angefangen haben, viel mehr Freiheit nachhaben, was sie denn jetzt mal als Prozess fahren können.
Stimmt.
Während in großen Firmen hast du, dann hast du zwar jemanden, der zuständig ist, aber der hat halt irgendwie einen Nagel und drei Hemmer.
Du kannst halt nur Java Enterprise machen, alles andere geht halt nicht.
Naja, der sieht halt die Sachen, die er hat, als die Tools, die er hat. Der geht halt damit in den Krieg, was er hat. So der wird nicht anfangen, jetzt radikale Dinge auszuprobieren, sondern der sagt halt, okay, pass auf, wir machen jetzt Fuzzing. Ja, das ist komplett unkontrovers, das tut keinem weh, das kostet ein bisschen CPU-Zeit auf irgendwelchen Servern. Am besten bei Amazon in der Cloud, da ist dann auch irgendwie... Ja, also ich habe mich da vor einer Weile angefangen, darüber aufzuregen, aus einem anderen Winkel heraus, weil es nämlich dazu geführt hat, dass die Prozesse, die bei den Metriken rausfallen, bevorzugt werden gegenüber denen, die was bringen. Klar, so willst du sehen müssen. Ja, genau, aber das heißt halt, in großen Firmen, wenn du die Wahl hast zwischen einem Prozess, der wirklich was bringt, wo die Metrik aber nicht gut ist, also wo die nicht viel aussagt und nicht impressive ist, oder sowas wie Fuzzing, wo du sagen kannst, wir haben jetzt drei Milliarden Durchgänge und wir haben hier diesen Graph, der zeigt, wie viele CPU-Stunden das verbraten hat. Ja, ich habe ja einmal dieses Ding gehabt, das erzähl ich immer gern, da hat mich ein Kunde nach hause geschickt, hat gesagt, nee, hier ist es gerade warm. Unsere Klimaanlage ist stark genug, entweder für das Fuzzing-Lab oder für die Consultants. Wir machen jetzt Fuzzing. Und haben mich ins Hotel zurückgeschickt. Und da dachte ich so, alles klar. Und Fuzzing, ja, da hat sich dann rausgestellt, irgendwie, die haben die Mutation-Engine falsch konfiguriert. Der hat immer denselben Test-Case gefasst. Aber die Metrix sah geil aus.
Na gut, aber ich meine, man muss ja schon sagen, dass seit AFL Fuzzing jetzt nicht mehr völlig ohne Berechtigung ist.
Nee, Fuzzing ist jetzt nicht ist nicht aktiv scheiße.
Aber wenn du die Wahl hast, wenn es das Einzige ist, was du tust, dann hast du natürlich Probleme.
Ja, aber so das ist halt, ich glaube, dass man es verallgemeinern kann, dass Sachen, Sachen, die wo eine Metrik rausfallen, wenn immer bevorzugt. Und andersrum, selbst wenn eine Sache nicht inherent eine Metrik auswirft, kann es Probleme geben. Ich habe also mal den Typ kennengelernt, der bei Windows den Treiber-Fuzzer geschrieben hat. Also wenn du einen Treiber für Windows ausliefern wolltest, war das früher so, dass du den halt einfach ausgeliefert hast. Ja, und Microsoft hat irgendwann gesagt, okay, der muss jetzt aber signiert sein. Und die Signatur kriegst du nur, wenn du durch unseren Test-Parcours durchkommst. Und der Test-Parcours besteht im Wesentlichen aus diesem Tool. Ja, und der geht halt die Iotils durch und wirft der Mist gegen, guckt, ob es platzt. So, und dann sind die CPUs schneller geworden und der Typ hat dazugelernt und hat angefangen, sein Tool zu erweitern. Und dann hat der Management gesagt, ne, ne, roll das mal zurück. Denn es sieht jetzt aus, als wenn bestehende Software schlechter wird, als es gestern war.
Weil sein Fuzzing besser geworden ist.
genau. Und da war halt so, ja, das können wir nicht machen. Ja, und das ist das Problem, wenn du auf Metriken guckst, statt auf Ergebnisse. Da ist halt dann das Ziel, nicht mehr sichere Software zu schreiben, sondern die Metriken müssen besser werden. So, und diese Art von Metagaming kriegst du halt, wenn du anfängst, so falsche Anreize in deinem, als Ziel, in eine Zielfindung einzubauen. Und das, also das ist jetzt ein besonders schönes, plakatives Beispiel, aber da gibt's also mehr.
Das ist ein gutes Beispiel, weil halt irgendwie natürlich genau diese Frage von Management, will ja Selbstwirksamkeit haben, das heißt, die wollen halt ja irgendwie zeigen können, dass sie was getan haben.
Und das muss aber auch Ergebnisse zeigen.
genau, es muss halt dokumentierbare Ergebnisse geben, Metriken geben, Messbarkeit geben, Quantifizierbarkeit geben, ganz wichtig. Das lernen sie ja schon einmal eins irgendwie im MBA-Studium. Ist ja irgendwie immer, alles muss quantifizierbar sein, sonst ist es nix wert. Das ist halt das, was sie dir da von vornherein eintrichtern. Und das ist natürlich...
Ist ja auch, ist ja auch was dran. Aber das Problem, also was mir immer sehr wichtig ist, warum ich das überhaupt erzähle, es gibt hier keine bösen Menschen, es gibt nur böse Anreize.
Es gibt auch böse Menschen.
Es gibt auch böse Menschen, aber das ist also keiner von den Leuten, von denen ich hier erzähle, ist irgendwie böse, sondern die haben alle das Gute machen wollen, das Gute und Richtige. Halten sich auch für Kämpfer des Lichts gegen die Verdammtnis.
Ja, okay, gut, ja.
Ja, aber das reicht halt nicht.
Nee, und ich glaube halt, dass der Ansatz zu sagen, man versucht, ohne Grundlegendes Basiswissen in sicherer Softwareentwicklung, also ich meine, es wird den Leuten ja nicht beigebracht. Und die bekommen es ja immer noch, verlassen jedes Jahr Leute die Bildungsstätten in diesem Land und haben nicht eine einzige Stunde über sicheres Programmieren gehört. Die haben nicht mal gelernt, wie ein Buffer-Overflow-Exploit funktioniert, damit sie überhaupt ein bisschen ins Denken kommen, wie ihre Software vielleicht aussehen sollte. Von irgendwie so moderneren, irgendwie komplexeren Exploitmethoden haben die niemals gehört. Die wissen nicht mal, wie das funktioniert. Sie wissen, haben auch nicht mal eine Vorstellung davon, dass aus Daten plötzlich Code werden kann. Was ist der absolute Basic, was du verstehen musst, damit du überhaupt verstehen kannst, wieso deine Software kaputtgehen kann.
Wobei das muss wirklich jeder im Informatikstudium mindestens einmal gehört haben. Aber das ist eine Auswirkung. Nur bei Computer-Architektur wird dir beigebracht, was eine Haarwaren-Architektur ist. Das ist eine Zwangsvorlesung.
Okay, aber es wird ja bei der Architektur...
Aber dass es Auswirkungen hat, kriegen halt viele nicht mit.
Die kriegst du halt nicht zusammen. Und ich glaube, das ist halt genau dieses Problem, dass in dem Umblick, wo den Leuten beigebracht werden würde, nicht nur in Informatikstudien, sondern überall, wo Programmieren gelehrt wird, dass sicheres Programmieren möglich ist und was du halt dabei zumindest beachten sollst und was du dir vielleicht nochmal drauf schaffen solltest, wenn du in einem bestimmten Bereich irgendwie arbeitest. Ich halte das mittlerweile für ein extrem grundlegendes Problem unseres Bildungssystems, dass das halt nicht passiert. Und dass halt irgendwie dieses Detail auch nicht angegangen wird, weil halt einfach das Verständnis dafür, dass man halt nicht nur mit irgendwie Intrusion Detection Systemen und irgendwie Telemetrie und Quatsch halt irgendwie mehr Sicherheit erzeugt, ist halt immer noch nicht angekommen. Das ist halt immer noch irgendwie dieses Product Driven. Irgendwie, wir tun da mal noch ein paar mehr bunte Heftpflaster drauf denken. So und ich meine, es ist 2020, 20 mittlerweile. Wir sind immer noch an dem Punkt, wo halt irgendwie das sich immer noch anfühlt, als wäre 2005. So, seit der Security angeht, irgendwie letzten 15 Jahren ist außer ein paar neuen Programmiersprachen eigentlich nicht viel passiert.
Wir haben ein paar wichtige Twitter Hashtags gesetzt.
Ja, genau. Noch eine Twitter-Kampagne, dann wird alles gut.
Naja, also ich finde immer ist es nicht so wichtig, dass du verstehst, wie die Exploits funktionieren. Du musst aber verstehen, was exploitbar ist. Ja, und das geht natürlich Hand in Hand, aber eigentlich würde es reichen. Ich glaube, das Problem würde sich von selber lösen, wenn es in den Firmen den Anreiz gäbe, gute Software zu schreiben. Denn niemand geht morgens los und sagt, hey, heute schreibe ich mal so richtig beschissenes Software.
Manche Leute schon, aber es sind wenige.
Ja, gut, aber das ist nicht unser hauptproblem, sondern die meiste Software wird von Leuten geschrieben, die es eigentlich gerne richtig machen würden.
Ich glaube, die meisten von denen wollen eigentlich nur fertig werden, dass der Kram läuft. Das ist eigentlich das, was die meisten wollen.
Die hackern nicht, nee. Das Management möchte das immer.
Auch die Code.
Also das ist gut, das finde ich jetzt so ein richtig beschissenes, in der Spieleentwicklung, okay.
Nee, auch sonst so. Klar, die Leute haben alle so eine diffuse Angst davor, dass ihr Code exploitet wird, aber das ist halt mehr so ein, davon habe ich keine Ahnung. Das ist ganz schön schwierig. Ich hoffe mal, dass es mir nicht passiert, denken. Das ist wirklich so. Also das, bei ganz viele Leute, die halt so, sagen wir mal, so wild in Wiesn Software machen, für die ist halt einfach dieses Security-Ding ist halt so eine Dark Art, so ein Ding, wo sie keine Ahnung von haben. Die wissen nicht so.
Ja, wenn Voldewort mich angreift, habe ich halt verloren.
genau, exakt genau das. Also wirklich exakt. Teilweise sind es halt genau die Worte so, ne? Und wo halt das Verständnis dafür, dass es halt nur ein Handwerk ist, dass du halt irgendwie zumindest mal 90 Prozent der Angreifbarkeiten mit einfach soliden Handwerk wegmachen könntest, wenn du halt weißt, wie es geht, wenn es jemand beigebracht hat, wenn es dir irgendwie angelesen hast. Und teilweise ist es ja auch nur, dass du halt einfach nicht unsichere Komponenten weiterverwendest, sondern halt irgendwie Sachen nimmst, wo Leute schon mal drüber nachgedacht haben und das halt ein bisschen geordert und getestet haben. Weißt du, in der Krypto genau dasselbe. Ich meine, die Leute bauen immer noch Kryptosysteme mit Primitiven, wo du denkst, so Kinder, die sind seit zehn Jahren nicht mehr irgendwie state of the art. Die wollten wir schon.
Aber Triple Desk steht noch in diesem Standard.
Weißt du, du kannst immer noch Chipkarten mit Triple Desk kaufen. Und dann Zugangskontrolls.
Und 1024-Bit-RSA, so yay.
Und du denkst dir so, warum? Und der Grund ist dann halt Preis. Dann hast du halt irgendwie, ich meine, warum gibt es immer noch Chipkarten da draußen, so ein Zugangskontrollsystem, wo die Hersteller wissen, dass sie kaputt sind, weil die halt billiger sind. Wurde schon niemand machen. Ist ja vielleicht nicht so wichtig. Und wenn sie halt irgendwie das Sicherer haben wollen, nehmen sie unser High-Security-Produkt mit Triple Desk. So, das ist halt so die Denke dabei dann so. Und das ist halt so eine Fahrlässigkeit, wo, ich glaube, das wird halt einfach vor Haftung nicht weggehen.
Es gab ja früher immer diesen Spruch, noch niemand ist gefeuert worden, weil er IBM gekauft hat. Und das haben wir heute halt auch. Noch niemand ist gefeuert worden, weil er unsichere Software hergestellt hat. Das hat einfach keine Konsequenzen.
Aber zurück zu dem Punkt, dass die Leute eigentlich keinen Scheiß bauen wollen. Wenn wir das mal freundlich annehmen, dass das wahr ist, das ist zumindest für einen Großteil der Leute wahr, ist so, ne? Die Konsequenz muss ja aus meiner Sicht denn sein, dass sich mindestens irgendwie der Bund darum kümmert, dass es Lehrmaterialien gibt dafür. Also mindestens für die Universitäten. Und dass halt die Verpflichtung an die Universitäten geht, so wenn ihr Kohle von Bund für ihre Informatik haben wollt oder für irgendeine andere Fakultät, sei es Elektrotechnik, wo Programmieren auf dem Fahrplan steht, dann muss sicheres Programmieren mit x Wochenstunden da drin sein. Und hier ist unser Lehrmaterial dafür. Das wäre halt der Ansatz, den ich da halt irgendwie pflegen würde. Einfach nur, wenn die Leute nicht aufpassen, wenn sie irgendwie es nicht verstehen, wenn sie zu blöd sind dazu, wenn sie es nicht interessiert. Fine. So, dann ist das halt so. Das ist bei allen möglichen anderen Sachen genauso. Aber dass sie zumindest die Chance haben, es beigebracht zu bekommen und zu wissen, dass sie, wenn sie es nicht richtig machen, wenn es halt genau wie wenn du eine Elektroinstallation machst, da musst du halt auch wissen, wo der FI-Schalter hinkommt und wie der anzuschließen ist. Weil wenn du das nicht tust, sterben halt einfach Leute. Und wir sind mittlerweile an dem Punkt, wo man sagen muss, die Software, die du da gerade baust, du kannst nicht mehr wissen, ob die nicht irgendwann mal wo eingesetzt wird, wo Leute sterben oder Katzen. Gerade hatten wir dieses Ding mit diesem IoT-Roboter, und der halt irgendwie eine Woche lang irgendwie waren die halt alle offline, weil irgendwie der blöde Cloud-Service weg war. Das hat sich...
Da sind Katzen verhungert.
Hat sich der Programmierer, der irgendwie diese Fremder Komponente dazu geführt hat, dass es nicht funktioniert hat, vorher denken können, dass wegen ihm Katzen verhungern? Vermutlich nicht. Klar.
Wollte aber nicht.
Ich weiß.
Komm mal, also ich habe ja bei Audits häufig mit so Security-Abteilungen und Entwicklern zu tun. Und die Fälle, wo der Entwickler, wenn ich ihm einen Bug zeige, sagt, das ist exploitbar, sagt, die kannst du auf einer Hand abzählen. Fast alle Fälle sind Scheiße. Und deswegen glaube ich, es liegt nicht an der Bildung, sondern es liegt daran, dass wir den Leuten nicht die Zeit geben, das ordentlich zu machen. Ja, wenn du also ich, ich habe, ich habe neulich mal so, na ja, das ist jetzt natürlich plakativ, aber ich habe neulich mal einen Vortrag, und ich habe gesagt, okay, wer von ihnen glaubt denn, in seiner Firma läuft was falsch? Alle. Wer von ihnen hätte einen konkreten Vorschlag, was man besser machen könnte? Auch alle. Und dann habe ich gesagt, sehen Sie, das ist doch super, das ist doch die beste Problemkategorie. Du weißt, dass du ein Problem hast, und du weißt, was du besser machen könntest. Und so musst du das glaube ich sehen. Wir wissen, wie man Software besser macht. Aber wir machen es nicht, weil es andere Sachen gibt, die dem im Weg stehen. Es liegt nicht daran, dass die Leute doof sind. Was ein Buffer-Overflow ist, also ich will nicht bestreiten, dass es hier und da Leute gibt, die noch nie gehört haben, was ein Buffer-Overflow ist. Aber so was eine Sequel-Injection ist, hat jeder im Web-Umfeld mal gehört und trotzdem passieren sie. Und das liegt im Allgemeinen daran, aus meiner Sicht, dass wir den Leuten nie die Zeit geben, nochmal über ihren Code rüber zu gucken. Also ich erzähl immer, ich habe einmal einen Kunden gehabt, der hat seinen Mitarbeitern gesagt, pass auf, wenn du sonst nichts zu tun hast gerade, dann gehst du nochmal über deinen alten Code und was du in der Zwischenzeit dazugelernt hast, wendest du dann an. Der Code war so geil und das war Pearl-Code. Pearl, was normalerweise write-only ist. Kannst du nie wieder lesen, was du da geschrieben hast. Bei denen nicht. Und ich dachte so, wow, ja, das geht. Es geht, aber wir machen halt aus Management-Seite das Gegenteil dessen, sondern wir haben jetzt Agile. Und Agile ist ein Verfahren, wie du den Leuten das letzte bisschen Zeit wegoptimierst, weil du dafür sorgst, es gibt immer eine Liste aus Sachen, die noch gemacht werden müssen. Es gibt nie Zeit zu reflektieren. Es gibt nie Zeit nochmal nachzudenken, habe ich das jetzt eigentlich gut gemacht oder nicht, sondern es geht nur abhaken, next. Das heißt, das ist, glaube ich, wirklich schädlich. Das ist wie, wenn du Leute nicht schlafen lässt nachts. Man braucht Zeit, wo man nochmal reflektieren kann. Ist jetzt eigentlich richtig, was ich hier mache. Und du musst in einer Firma den Leuten Zeit geben, überhaupt mitzukriegen, wenn sie Scheiße gemacht haben. Denn häufig haben die Leute, kriegen die Leute mit. Das ist hier noch nicht zu Ende. Das ist noch nicht final, aber es ist vielleicht gut genug. Aber ist es wirklich gut genug oder nicht? Das ist eine Entscheidung, die du treffen kannst, nachdem du nochmal rüberguckst. Das kannst du nicht nach dem ersten Pass sagen, ob das jetzt gut ist oder nicht.
Na ja, aber letzten Endes hat das auch ganz viel damit zu tun, wie, welche Anforderungen du setzt. Und ich meine, das ist irgendwie so ein... Also wenn man jetzt mal so den... Ich emuliere gerade mal einen Agile-Jünger, ja? Also nur mal den. Ich bin kein Agile-Jünger, aber ich emuliere ihn gerade mal nur um das Argument Cyber. Und dann würdest du sagen so, okay. Dann setzt du halt einfach defensive Programmierung. Also dass du halt mit allen Input-Cases, die halt nicht für dich sanitized sind, irgendwie umgehen kannst. Beziehungsweise dass du keine anderen darüber machst, dass den Inputs überhaupt sanitized sind. Ist halt einfach ein Feature-Requirement, was halt irgendwie in deine Testsuit reingeht und was halt irgendwie getestet wird. Und deine Software ist halt nicht fertig, wenn es da halt nicht reingeht. Ja, dann würde man noch eher sagen, es ist halt eher ein Fehler in der Spezifikation und in der Zielsetzung von Software, die auf der Management-Ebene passiert wurde. Der Management dann halt sagt so, naja, wir wollen lieber mehr Feature-Punkte abhaken, als irgendwie das irgendwie jetzt dieser blöde, was war das, Sanitation, nimmt man da irgendwie so Propyl-Akkule für irgendwie?
Da bin ich ganz bei dir. Auf der anderen Seite ist es ja eine Verhandlung zwischen Management und Entwicklern, die Feature-Liste. Und die Entwickler sehen sich häufig völlig unnötig in so einer irgendwie Zwangslage, in der sie gar nicht drin sind. Also wenn ich sage, noch keiner ist gefeuert worden, weil er schlechten Code geschrieben hat, das liegt ja auch daran, dass man einfach kein Personal findet, gerade auf dem Markt.
Das stimmt.
Das heißt, du kannst im Grunde gar nicht dich so verhalten, dass du gefeuert wirst. Da musst du wirklich, wirklich krass Scheiße für machen. Aber die meisten Entwickler sind so drauf, dass sie lieber freiwillig über Stunden schieben, um ihr irrationales Projektziel in dem vorgegebenen Zeitrahmen abzuhanken. Und das ist ein gravierender Fehler gegenüber dem Management. Denn das Management ist ja trainierbar. Das Management nimmt ja Input und reagiert darauf. Und wenn du immer rechtzeitig fertig wirst, weil du am Wochenende Überstunden schiebst, dann lernt der Manager daraus, ja, das war offenbar eine realistische Annahme, dass du in der Zeit das erreichen kannst.
Stretchgoals.
Ja, genau. Und der Manager wird dann eher versuchen, dir noch ein bisschen weniger Zeit zu geben, weil er befürchtet, dass er Geld verplempert. Das heißt, du optimierst nur deine eigenen Schmerzen in der Zukunft nach oben, wenn du dich unrealistischen Zielen hingebst. Und deswegen ist einer meiner Vorschläge gewesen, dass du sagst als Entwickler, wenn jemand ein Stück Kot fordert von dir und du hast die Wahl, das gut oder schlecht zu machen, dass du dann dem nicht die Wahl gibst, ob du das gut oder schlecht machst, sondern du machst es gut. Und wenn es länger dauert, dann dauert es halt länger. Denn so lernt der Manager, dass das halt länger dauert. Wenn du sagst, okay, pass auf, ich spar mir jetzt hier die Sanitierung, weil das kostet ja nur Zeit. Und der, der mich aufruft, der würde es schon gemacht haben. Das ist halt erzeugt, bei dem, der dich aufruft, genauso gelaufen. Der wird dann auch sagen, ja, pass auf, das kann ja der machen, den ich hier aufrufe. Das heißt, wenn du das überhaupt scheiße anbietest, ist schon der Fehler. Du als Programmierer bist der, der sagen kann, ich biete das gar nicht an. Ein Auto, was nicht fahren kann, biete ich nicht an. Ja, das ist bei Autos...
Aber es fährt ja, es klappert halt nur ein bisschen.
Na, es zerfällt halt, wenn die Sonne drauf schallt.
Nicht schief angucken, okay.
Geht nur. In der Garage fährt er gut, aber sobald oder wenn einer Klebestreifen an den Schildern anbringt, dann gibt es schon mal irgendwie Unfälle.
Ja, Details, Details.
Nee, aber ich glaube, wir müssen einfach sehen als Entwickler, dass die Macht, das richtig zu machen, bei uns liegt. Und wir müssen einfach machen. Ja, gar nicht so tun. Irgendwie der, der am Ende moralisch schuld ist und der sein Leben lang unglücklich sein wird, wenn seine Wegen Leute gestorben sind, ist der Entwickler. Das Management rationalisiert sich das weg. Du als Entwickler bist der, der sagen muss, ne, das biete ich nicht an, das ist noch nicht fertig. Das kannst du noch nicht ausliefern. Das ist ja dein Input, wenn du dem sagst, ja, also pass auf, ich bin noch nicht ganz fertig, aber es geht schon, dann sagt der Manager, perfekt.
Schippe.
genau, wird ausgeliefert. Der Updater läuft.
Und die Telemetrie.
Das läuft, genau. Updater und Telemetrie müssen gehen, der Rest nicht so wichtig. Und diese Macht müssen wir halt nutzen als Entwickler.
Naja, ich habe aber glaube ich so ein bisschen das Problem, dass ich häufiger Sachen sehe, wo die Entwickler es noch nie richtig gemacht haben. Also wo es halt so diese Erfahrung von richtig defensive, schussigere Software bauen. Entweder weil sie noch nicht so weit sind oder weil sie halt nie die Chance dazu hatten.
Das will ich nicht in Abrede stellen.
Oder weil sie auch einfach nicht das Wissen haben. Also eigentlich hätten sie gerne so ein Framework, was das für sie tut. Was sie halt irgendwie reinlinken und was sich dann darum kümmert. Das wäre eigentlich das, was sie gerne wollen, weil diesen ganzen Quatsch zu machen, sich um diese Inputs zu kümmern und alle Fälle durchzudenken, wie man die halt sanitizen muss und so weiter und so fort. Und irgendwie all die ganzen Probleme, die du halt irgendwie gerade Multistrader-Software, na also wenn du da halt irgendwie...
Ja, es wird immer noch schlimmer.
Dann wird es halt nur noch schlimmer so. Also ich meine, gut, Multistrader-Software ist auch nicht ein schon ein Problem, aber ist halt so, dass halt diese Art zu denken und so dieses defensiv programmiert Denken, das wird halt einfach auch eine Gewöhnungssache ist. Und wo man die Leute auch erstmal hinbekommen muss, dass sie so an Sachen rangehen, dass sie halt wirklich jeden Scheiß, wie man dieser Software üblich mitspielen könnte, halt mitdenken. Und das passiert halt einfach auch nicht, weil sie halt irgendwie davon ausgehen, dass das passt.
Ich würde noch einen Schritt weiter gehen und sagen, den Weg gibt es auch gar nicht. Also es ist nicht, es gibt jetzt nicht irgendwie das Buch, wo man irgendwie die reinschreiben könnte, wenn du das und das machst, ist alles gut, sondern es hängt eben auch von der Domain ab, in der du dich bewegst. Und einiges ist auch einfach Perspektivsache. Also ich will mal illustrieren. Es gibt, man kann entweder sagen, okay, ich will diese und jene Zugriffsicherung haben, die implementiere ich jetzt. Oder man sagt, okay, was kann denn das Betriebssystem machen? Und dann entwickelt man seine Architektur darum herum, um die existierenden Sicherheitssachen und Delegiertes sozusagen. Und diesen Weg hat Kummel beschritten. Ja, Kummel hat den beschritten und hat noch nie eine Exploit gehabt, gab noch nie ein CVE. Es gab einmal eine Sache, die die hätte ich eingeschätzt als Sicherheitslücke. Da hat der Autor nicht anerkannt. Aber so im Wesentlichen ist die Architektur so sauber, weil der halt keine Security Sachen selber macht, sondern alles aufs System delegiert. Der hat einfach keine Angriffspunkte. Und das ist so eine radikale andere Herangehensweise, dass selbst der Autor Probleme hatte, das zu verstehen. Er hat nämlich vor ein paar Jahren eine Retrospektive geschrieben, wo er gesagt hat, also er glaubt ja nicht, dass diese ganze Architektur geholfen hat. Mein Code war einfach lückenlos. War sozusagen seine Zusammenfassung. Und das stimmt halt nicht, sondern ich habe mir die Zeit nicht genommen, seinen Code anzugreifen, weil die Architektur schon verhindert, dass ich irgendwas machen kann, wenn ich den jetzt angreife. Aber das siehst du halt nicht. Das ist ein Problem davon, was du sehen kannst. Wenn du siehst, mich hat nie einer angegriffen, kann das entweder daran liegen, dass deine Telemetrie scheiße ist, du siehst es halt nicht. Oder es kann sein, es hat dich wirklich keiner angegriffen, weil deine Software zu obskur ist. Oder es kann heißen, es hat niemand versucht, weil der Gewinn zu klein ist, der beim Erfolg. Wenn die Architektur so geil ist, dass du einfach nichts erreichen kannst, also der SMTP-Server, das ist der, der einkommende Mails annimmt, der hat genau genug Permissions, um eine Mail ins Fallsystem zu schreiben.
An genau die Stelle, wo sie hin soll.
genau die Stelle. genau. So, das heißt, wenn du die Netz exploitest, kannst du genau das tun, was du auch ohne exploit gekäut hättest. Und wenn du deine Software so designst, hast du keine Probleme, aber da musst du erst mal hinkommen. Ja, und der war da seinerzeit echt voraus. Und ich kenne ja Leute, die exploitsentwickeln. Hab mich mit denen noch mal unterhalten. Wie ist denn das mit Qmer, man ja. Warum soll ich das denn angreifen? Hier ist doch alles. Bringt ja nichts. So. Mails kann ich auch so. Spam kann ich auch so.
Ja, stimmt.
Ja, so. Und das stimmt. Und das ist aber erweiterbar auf andere Dienste. Und wir haben ja auch neue. Es ist ja nicht so, dass dir komplett statisch ist, was man so für ein Arsenal hat. Also Open SSH zum Beispiel ist da federführend gewesen beim Einführen von Privilege Separation ist das Konzept, was sie eingeführt haben, dass man sagt, innerhalb von meinem von meinem Service habe ich jetzt einen einen Teil, der läuft als User A und ich habe einen Teil, der läuft als User B und User B sieht nur irgendwie dieses eine Verzeihnis, in dem man nur lesen darf und so weiter und so fort. Und da sind keine Dateien drin. Und das Handshake bei Open SSH findet statt in so einem Jail. Das heißt, wenn es einen gültigen Exploit gibt, dann ist er halt in dem Jail drin und kann nichts. Alles, was der machen kann, ist nach außen sagen, das war der Key und dann sagt der außen, ja mit dem Key kommst du aber nicht rein, dann bist du da, wo du vorher warst. Das heißt, man kann architekturell dafür sorgen, dass eine Software nicht angreifbar ist. Oder zumindest nur so wenig angreifbar, dass der Angreifer lieber Sendmail hackt. Was wir aber in der Industrie sehen, ist den gegenteiligen Trend, dass die Leute nicht ihre Software um das Betriebssystem rumentwickeln, sondern in existierende Software versuchen, irgendwelche Barrieren reinzukummeln nachträglich. Und tatsächlich wird die Software auch nicht kleiner, weil sie mehr delegiert hat, sondern sie wird immer größer. Also so ein aktuelles Chrom-Binary unter Unterliebnis ist irgendwie 200 MB oder so. Das ist unfassbar.
Und ich verstehe auch nicht warum.
Ja, ich glaube, da gibt es also, ich habe auch keine, kann dir auch nicht erklären warum so groß ist.
Also es ist halt irgendwie so diese, diese Bloatware, die man da mittlerweile irgendwie mit sich rumschleppt, ist halt so, also ich habe immer so den Verdacht bei den Browsern, dass da immer noch so jede Menge Funktionen drin sind, die nie jemand benutzt außer zum Exploiten. So, also halt irgendwie keine Ahnung, was es noch alles kann. Also so gerade.
Allein die Liste der Sachen, die so ein Browser kann, ist ein derartig bewegliches Ziel. Das wirkt auf mich teilweise als wenn es ein Trinkspiel kippt zwischen den Browser-Herstellern. So, ey, wir haben doch was eingebaut hier, pass auf, pass auf. Und dann guckst du so, ey, wirklich? Also das ist so die Sache, die mich so am meisten stört an der Software um mich rum, dass das einfach alles immer nur größer wird. Wir haben vorhin beim Reingehen, haben wir kurz darüber geredet, dass es ja das vom BSI jetzt die Ansage gibt, die Gerätehersteller, also insbesondere Smartphones, sollen mindestens fünf Jahre Patches liefern. Und teilweise ist es ja ein Problem in der, in der Realität Patches zu liefern für Systeme, weil die Software mit den Patches immer größer wird und weil die dann irgendwann nicht mehr passt. Ja, da war zu wenig Flash oder zu wenig RAM. Das hat es ja tatsächlich mehrfach gegeben, dass irgendwie Plastorouter aus den Patches rausgefallen sind, weil die neue Version nicht mehr passt.
Zumal oder du musst dann halt eine extrem riskante Patch, das ist die riskante Patch-Methode verwenden, weil idealerweise, wenn du halt so ein embedded-Gerät hast, willst du ja halt doppelt so viel Flash haben, wie du eigentlich brauchst, dass du halt einfach...
Damit du, wenn das nicht läuft, hast du immer noch ein funktionierendes Image.
genau, also du flashst halt einfach das neue Image, hast halt daneben Platz für das alte Image. Und wenn es neu nicht funktioniert, fällt es aufs alte zurück. Das ist halt so. Und wenn du dann halt irgendwie darüber hinauskommst, also dazu sagen, dein Flash kleiner, also nicht mehr für zwei Images reicht, dann musst du halt dir entweder überlegen, dass du den Router abkündigst und aus dem Update-Prozess nimmst oder dass du sagst, okay, ich lade mir da halt so ein kleines Flash-OS drauf, was dann halt irgendwie, also Hail Mary halt irgendwie da, die hofft, dass der Flash noch heile ist nach dem Schreiben, ersten Schreiben nach fünf Jahren oder so.
Ja, oder es kann ja auch logisch kaputt sein, das muss ja nicht ein Hardware-Fehler sein.
Klar, aber hoffentlich ist es halt ein Hardware-Fehler.
Ja, aber nicht immer.
Ja, aber gerade so bei Plastoroutern hast du halt halt hoffentlich den billigsten Flash ohne irgendwie Releveling den du mir vorstellen kannst. Und dann geht's halt leider auch aufwiegend schief.
Ja, und da hab ich vorhin gemeint, das ist ja meine Hoffnung, wenn wir so was einführen, dass das dazu führt, dass es auch mal einen Anreiz gibt, Software nicht wachsen zu lassen. Ja, wenn die Hersteller gezwungen sind, fünf Jahre Patches zur Verfügung zu stellen. Und ich find ja fünf Jahre noch an der Untergrenze. Ja, weil das heißt de facto, dass mir der Hersteller vorschreiben kann, dass ich nur fünf Jahre lang das Produkt weiterverkaufen kann. Ja, das würden wir sonst nirgendswo dulden. Stellen man sich mal vor, dass VW sagt, ja, also das Auto, was ich hier gerade verkauft habe, das kannst du schon weiter verkaufen, aber das geht nur drei Jahre lang.
Hat doch Tesla gerade gemacht.
Ja, das finde ich auch. Das ist unglaublich.
Tesla hat doch irgendwie da den, den, den, den irgendwie Assisted Driving Modus rausgenommen.
Ja, go fuck yourselves.
Ja, das wäre tatsächlich auch so ein Grund da mal irgendwie.
Ich glaube, die sind auch echt unzufrieden gewesen, die Leute, die dann, der Drive, der Autodrive, wie es der Autopilot nicht mehr ging.
Ja, ich glaube, diese, diese Frage mit dem, wie lange halten denn die Geräte und wie lange werden die Hersteller verpflichtet, die zu supporten, ist aus mehreren Aspekten, glaube ich, eigentlich der richtige Ansatz. Also zum einen wird es dazu führen, dass Geräte länger halten, weil die, also ihre tatsächliche Verwendbarkeit halt einfach länger wird, weil sie teurer werden, weil die Hersteller müssen halt den gesamten Lifecycle-Kost für die fünf Jahre mit einberechnen, wenn es kommt. Das BSI hatte halt erstmal nur als Security-Anforderungen für Smartphones für behördliche Anwendungen gemacht. Das heißt, es wird halt ein paar Hersteller geben, wahrscheinlich Samsung und Apple, die anderen werden es nicht machen.
Das ist erstmal so ein Testballon, um zu sehen, ob die Industrie laut heult oder sehr laut heult.
Ich meine, Apple hat da keinen Stress mit, ne? Also die Apple sagt dir halt jetzt irgendwie, alles, was 64-Bit ist, supporten wir, solange wir wieder fleschreich zogen. Also da haben die ja keinen Stress mit. Kann halt sein, dass du dann keine Apps mehr installieren kannst, weil es irgendwie Betriebssysteme zu sein sind, das es riegelbar wird, aber supportet wird es. Und also Apple hat ja diesen Kacken nur gemacht, bei den 32-Bit, weil sie die loswerden wollten.
Na Android auch.
Dass sie gesagt haben, irgendwie alles nach, was später ist, können wir halt noch so supporten. Und ich meine, bei Samsung, die haben halt, glaube ich, eher so Treiberprobleme. Also dass sie dann halt einfach so Sachen backporten müssen. Also bei Android zum Beispiel ist halt das Problem, dass wenn du halt so ein Android-Phone baust, von GSP zu Qualcomm, sagst du, ich hätte gern ein Chipset von euch, und dann kriegst du von Qualcomm halt dann irgendwie so eine Android-Version, die dafür gebaut ist, auf der Basis von dem Android Open Source Project von ASP. Und da ist dann halt der ganze Treiberquatsch drinne für dieses Baseband.
Aber das ist dann nicht etwa ein Linux-Körnerl mit ein paar Treibern, sondern es ist ein handgebackener irgendwie 3.8-Uralt-Antik-Schweineköpfe.
genau, weil nämlich die die Baseband-Hersteller, also in dem Fall zum Beispiel Qualcomm, sagt halt, diese Baseband verkaufen wir seit drei Jahren nicht mehr, da porten wir keine Treiber mehr nach vorne für Android 9. Ja, und dann stehst du halt da mit deinem Telefon und hast halt dann Android 6 oder 7 drauf. Und kannst ja halt überlegen, was du tust, und fängst halt an Security-Backcoding zu machen. Das sind halt so Folgerungen, die ja viel weiter vorne anfangen, wo der eigentlich Telefonhersteller häufiger gar nicht so viel dafür kann, außer dass er halt, also gerade wenn er halt kleiner ist. Also ich meine, der Samsung kann natürlich zu Qualcomm gehen, sagen so, Kinders, wenn ihr wollt, dass ihr nur ein dreimal zweiter Qualcomm kaufen, supportet ihr dieses Gerät jetzt bitte auch unter Android 9. Aber wenn du halt irgendwie so ein kleiner China-Walten-Wiesen-Hersteller bist, dann sagst du halt, naja, dann machen wir halt was Qualcomm, da können wir ja nichts für, ne?
Naja, aber wo soll denn der Druck auf Qualcomm herkommen, außer über so ein Hebel?
Na, das wird halt, also diese...
Muss doch so, oder siehst du deinen anderen Weg.
Also meine Vermutung ist, dass diese Forderung zu sagen, fünf Jahre Support, wenn die für den gesamten Markt durchgesetzt wird, würde dazu eine massiven Konzentration führen. Das würde dazu führen, dass es nun noch sehr wenige Hersteller gibt. Das ist genau das selbe Effekt, den du halt haben wirst, wenn du sagst, ok, du hast halt Security-Anforderungen, zum Beispiel für einen Betrieb von Servern. Der Effekt davon wird nicht sein, dass die Leute qualifizierte Süßheitseinstellung sagen, die werden dorthin gehen und sagen, ok, liebe T-Systems, dann betreibt ihr mal für mich meine Server. Weil ihr könnt halt wenigstens oder liebes Google oder liebes Amazon. Also was auch immer.
Jetzt jetzt nicht ein anderes Beispiel.
Na gut, ich hab ja Google und Amazon hinterher gesagt. Also jedenfalls, es würde halt dazu führen, dass Security-Outsourcing passiert an die Großen, die die entsprechenden Prozesse dafür haben und die entsprechende finanzielle Tiefe, um halt irgendwie mit Problemen umgehen zu können. Das ist halt so eine Folgerung, die man halt durchaus auch im Auge behalten sollte, wo mir bisher noch keine richtig gute Lösung eingefallen ist dafür. Außer zu sagen, wenn es halt irgendwie eine Software-Basis gibt, die zumindest bei den Treiber-Geschichten ist, ist halt immer schwierig, aber so bei allgemeinen Software-Komponenten, die halt wohl auditiert um Source-Software ist, die staatlich gefördert dafür gesorgt wird, dass die halt einfach da sind, existiert so.
Ich finde noch einen wichtigen Punkt, dass es ja Fälle gab, in denen Samsung Code bei Linux eingereicht hat, in den Standardkörner. Und der war so scheiße, der Code, dass Linux gesagt hat, okay, das bleibt hier in Quarantäne. Und zwar jahrelang. Also es geht konkret um den Exfalt-Code. Das ist so die aktuelle iteration von Fettfallsystemen, was auf Flash speichern drauf ist. Ja, und das gammelt jahrelang in der Quarantäne rum. Und jetzt haben sie gerade gesagt, naja, dann machen wir mal einen Rewrite, der kommt demnächst. Ja, das heißt...
Hat Samsung gesagt oder haben die anderen...
Nein, Linux hat das gesagt. Samsung hat gesagt, naja, okay, es gibt einen Rewrite demnächst. Aber der Punkt ist, Samsung wird ja nicht irgendeinen Gammelcode submitted haben, sondern das, was sie gedacht haben, was der beste Code ist, den sie haben. Ja, das... na, aber natürlich. Du machst dich doch nicht zum Stück Brot und committest was von dem Beweis, ob du scheiße bist. Nein, da bin ich mir ganz sicher. Das war das, wovon sie dachten, das ist gut. Ja, der Rest ist... Also das ist, worauf ich gerade hinaus will. Wenn ich jetzt irgendwie ein Zocker wäre, würde ich aber... meine Kohle wäre auf, der Rest ist noch viel beschissener. Es hat ja einen Hintergrund, dass die alle irgendwie einen Dreierlinux-Könnel ausliefern. Wenn wir inzwischen bei, was weiß ich, wo sind wir, 5.5, demnächst 5.6. Das hat ja einen Hintergrund, dass wir da irgendwie einen Körner von vor 5 Jahren haben. Das liegt aber daran, dass die Treiber alle so kacke sind, dass sie mit dem aktuellen Körner nicht gehen. Ja, und dass Treiber angefasst werden müssen bei neuen Körnerversionen, das gibt es immer wieder mal. Aber das ist aber nicht so schlimm, dass es irgendwie ein Hinderungsgrund wäre.
Naja, warum ist unter Android immer noch so fossile Körner? genau deswegen.
Naja, eben. Das ist ja, worauf ich hinaus will. Das heißt, wir haben hier im Grunde, was uns zurückhält, ist sowas wie Qualcomm halt.
Ja, klar.
Und da muss man irgendwie ran. Und ich glaube, der einzige Weg da ranzukommen ist, indem man den Leuten die Qualcomm-Scheiß am weiterverkaufen, Auflagen macht, gesetzliche. Weil da kann dann auch Samsung nichts für, wenn sie an die Auflage gebunden sind. Und da wird Qualcomm dann auch nicht sagen, na dann liefern wir halt nicht mehr an Samsung, weil das ja alle betrifft. Also irgendwo muss der Druck herkommen.
Naja, also vielleicht ist jetzt so ja so der, diese die Absage, das war bei World Congress wegen Corona.
Ist jetzt ein gutes, guter Anlass, um da mal...
Guter Anlass, um mal so ein bisschen halt einfach die Geschwindigkeit daraus zu nehmen. Aber gerade in dieser ganzen Mobiltelefonbranche ist halt irgendwie diese Atemlosigkeit mit irgendwie sechsmal einem Produkt-Release-Cycle führt halt nicht dazu, dass da irgendwas besser wird. Und ich meine, es ist ja kein Wunder, dass Google sagt, sie wollen jetzt einfach die Android-Devices direkt updaten.
Aber es ist ja nicht nur...
OEMs ist halt nicht hinbekommen.
Es ist ja nicht nur so, dass die Sicherheit nicht besser wird, sondern auch die Features, die du irgendwie wirklich brauchst in den neuen Versionen.
Hey, aber dafür hörte...
Weiß ich seit ein paar Jahren nicht mehr, was da jetzt irgendwie, wie soll ich da eigentlich updaten hätte sollen.
Aber Herr Wesse, dein aktuelles Android-Telefon hörte dafür die ganze Zeit zu.
Ja, super.
Dann kannst du irgendwie sagen, OK Google oder...
Ey, jetzt, dafür kriegen wir böse Mails jetzt.
Hallo Siri.
Alexa!
genau. Und dann, ja, also ich glaube, dass halt diese diese Vorstellung von Features, die die Leute wirklich brauchen und wollen, die sind da schon ganz schön weit weg von, von dem, was wirklich trotz aller Telemetrie...
Dafür haben wir jetzt noch ein geileres UI Fabric, irgendwie Standard.
Mit...
Wie hieß das?
Wasserwellen, Wobbeldinger, Simulacenter, Fashion Sonne.
Und dann so, ja, aber gut, der Akku hält jetzt nur noch zwei Minuten, aber hey.
Aber look how fast it is.
genau. Of course it doesn't work, ist der alte Spruch. Of course it doesn't work, but look how fast it is.
Na gut. Jedenfalls, die Softerkrise wird so schnell nicht vorbeigehen. Aber lass uns mal noch ein bisschen über irgendwie weniger deprimierte Themen reden. Was haben wir denn noch so?
Prepper haben wir noch.
Ach so, Prepping und Corona haben wir noch. Ja, gut, das wird den weniger deprimierten Themen. Naja, das ist halt, also ich meine, das ist eigentlich wieder genau das selbe Phänomen so. Also das ist halt so, die Leute haben jetzt alle Desinfektionsmittel und Atemmasken weggekauft und irgendwie die Regierung hat es irgendwie zu spät mitbekommen. Jetzt haben wir keine mehr für die Krankenhäuser.
Aber das fand ich eigentlich bemerkenswert. Die haben gleich die guten Atemmasken gekauft. Es gibt da Standards, FF, also was jetzt ausverkauft ist.
Alle sind ausverkauft.
Ja, aber eben auch die guten, teuren, die die Krankenhäuser benutzen.
Die FFP3-Masken.
genau, da war ich so ein bisschen beeindruckt, muss ich sagen, weil das sind jetzt eigentlich schon, das sind nicht so Karnevalsdinger, sondern die haben.
Ja, aber ich meine, die Leute haben wirklich alles gekauft. So, und das ist halt irgendwie so ein, so ein. Und das Problem ist halt, dass der...
Warum ist das denn schlecht?
Ja, das ist eigentlich, weil der Staat seine Vorsorgepflicht nicht erfüllt hat. Was der Staat hätte machen sollen beim ersten Anzeichen, dass es in China da irgendwie rund geht. Wer hätte jetzt in den Händlern gehen müssen, sagen müssen, das Lager da hinten, da kommt jetzt mal ein bundesaufkleber drauf. Und wenn da eine Maske rausgeht, die nicht an ein krankenhaus geht, dann wird es hier ungemütlich. Das hätten die da einfach mal tun sollen. genau das wäre für Schutzanzüge und Schutzbrillen.
Du, ich glaube, das Problem ist, es gibt gar keine Lager.
Doch, klar. Ich meine, was denkst du, wie viele Millionen Masken über Amazon verkauft wurden? Natürlich gibt es die.
Na, also ist das alle just in time? Scheiße.
Ach, quatsch nicht. Das ist so billiges Zeug, das wird nicht geflogen, geht im Container. Und so ein Container voller Masken hält eine Weile.
Naja, aber die kommen per Schiff immer, dass der nächste Container reinkommt.
Ja, da kommen dann halt ein paar Container so. Und die kannst du halt natürlich, gibt es da eine Bevorratung für so Zeug, gab es so. Und ich meine, das ist halt völlig beknackt. Ja, der Staat ist nicht mal mehr in der Lage, von irgendwie für so eine relativ überschaubare Problemlage rechtzeitig Vorsorge zu treffen. Also, dass wir jetzt in dieser Situation sind, wo wir in Deutschland Krankenhäuser haben, wo, ich meine, Twitter ist gerade voll davon, wo irgendwie Krankenschwestern sagen, ja, uns wurde gesagt, wir sollen jetzt halt irgendwie nur noch einen Schutzanzug und eine Schutzmaske pro Patient pro Tag verwenden.
Ja, nee, deswegen meine ich das, selbst wenn du das bevorratest, gehen die durch eine Menge Masken.
Das ist ja okay. Dafür sind die da. Deswegen sind die ein Wegprodukt, damit die hinterincineratet werden kannst. Die schmeißt einfach in den Verbrenner. Exakt genau dafür sind die da.
Du brauchst halt so einen gewissen Durchsatz. Das hätte man schon mal berechnen können. Wie viel brauchen wir eigentlich, um hier einen Monat auszuhalten?
brauchen wir eigentlich davon. Dann hätte man die halt einfach mal bevorratet. Und zwar zu Zeiten, wo das Zeug noch gab.
Da hat sich die unsichtbare Hand des Marktes drum gekümmert.
genau, auf Amazon. So wo du jetzt mittlerweile Masken für einen Zehner kaufen kannst, die vorher 20 Cent gekostet haben oder so. Das ist halt so ein Ding, wo da habe ich halt so das Gefühl, dass wir mit dem, also was wir vorhin geredet haben, diese Softwareprobleme.
Nicht mal wenn es ums Menschenleben geht.
Da sind wir halt noch auf einem extrem hohen Abstraktionslevel, was irgendwie wirklich nicht verstanden wird, weil wenn die nicht mal in der Lage sind für so eine Situation, die absehbar war. Ich meine, das war jetzt wirklich mit Ansagen. Wir sind jetzt acht Wochen nach dem, klar war, in China brennt irgendwas an. Spätestens Mitte Januar hätte man sehen können, das mit dem Containment wird wahrscheinlich nix. Lass mal lieber noch mal ein bisschen Kram ordern.
Ja, pass mal auf, das Problem ist ja, man hätte es ja produzieren können.
Es gibt ja sogar Werke in Europa, die brauchen halt nur vorlauf. Ist ja nicht so, dass das irgendwie alles aus China kommt.
Ja, aber die sind halt nicht im normalen, in einer normalen Circulation drin, sondern was jetzt passiert ist, ist, dass bei dem Hafen einfach keine Container mehr ankam aus China, weil die Chinesen gesagt haben, ja die Masten brauchen wir gerade selber.
Aber wenn die halt mit die anderen gesagt hätten, okay, das, was da China anbrennt, brennt uns möglicherweise auch an, dann wären sie zu den europäischen Herstellern gegangen und gesagt so, macht mal, Kinas, das, was jetzt irgendwie hier produziert wird, wandert bei euch ins Lager, das geht nicht auf Amazon. So, und das geht halt auch nicht auf Ebay.
Ja, aber dann machen die ja Verlust, auf Amazon kannst du zehn Euro aufrufen pro Maske, habe ich gerade gehört.
Aber irgendwelche Glückswörter, die das Zeug schon aufgekrieft haben.
Du, aber da sind wir wieder bei meiner Telemetrietheorie. Ja, was ich übrigens, die ist mir übrigens das erste Mal gekommen beim Betrachten der Brücken in Deutschland, dass wir jetzt seit zehn, 15 Jahren einfach einmal pro Jahr, zweimal pro Jahr in der Presse lesen, die Brücken in Deutschland sind alle marode. So und so viel Prozent sind akut einsturzgefährdet. Und dann denke ich mir, wenn du die Zahl hast, was hindert dich daran? Hallo? Wieso?
worauf wartet ihr? genau.
Also da fehlt mir doch echt die Wörter. Ja, aber so ist es halt. Wir investieren in Telemetrie. Wir wissen jetzt genau, welche Brücken einsturzgefährdet sind.
Und lassen wir noch ein paar Eurofighter kaufen.
Ja, genau.
Und noch ein bisschen Cum-Ex.
Die haben wir ja schon bezahlt, die Eurofighter. Also fast. Wir haben uns verpflichtet, sie zu bezahlen.
genau. Und wie gesagt, und noch mal ein bisschen Cum-Ex. Cum-Ex, so hätte vielleicht nur wir rechnen können.
Wenn wir das zurückfordern, dann gehen die Banken pleite. Das geht ja nicht.
Hey, man könnte aber die Brücken davon sanieren und vielleicht sogar Medikamenten.
Was nützt dir denn eine Brücke, wenn die Banken pleite sind?
Ja, das stimmt. Und ich meine, genau das selbe halt irgendwie für diesen ganzen Pharmakram. Also ich hab mich da mit jemandem unterhalten, der irgendwie mal in der Branche früher tätig war, bevor halt irgendwie die ganze Rohstoffproduktion nach China outgesourct wurde. Also bevor die halt nur in den Wohltig, die ganzen Pharma-Rohstoffe für die Standardmedikamente herkommen. Und ist schon etwas älterer Herr. Und hab den halt gefragt, so naja, wie viel ist denn das eigentlich so? Na also, um wie viel, wovon reden wir hier eigentlich? So nimm mal so ne Tonne Zeug, was du brauchst, um Ibuprofen zu machen. Also wie ist denn da der Preisunterschied? Wenn man den mal so auf so ne Tablette runterrechnet. Meint er, naja, auf so ne Tablette runtergerechnet, dann vielleicht einen Cent, vielleicht auch zwei oder so, ist der Preisunterschied, wenn du das halt hier irgendwie bei BASF, in Ludwigshafen brauen lässt oder da halt irgendwo in China. Lass es fünf Cent sein, so ne?
Dabei da gehen vier Cent für deine Qualitätskontrolle drauf, oder?
Nö, das ist die Qualität schon okay. Also das, was da von da kommt mittlerweile, das haben die schon im Griff. Das Problem ist halt nur, das kommt halt gerade nicht von da, ne? Und der meint ja halt so, das Krasse ist halt, dass die absolute Einsparung ist halt jetzt nicht so kostet die Hälfte oder kostet ein Viertel oder so. Irgendwo, wo du denken würdest, naja, da kann man ja schon mal, sondern es geht halt um so ein maximal zweistellige Prozentzahlen, die halt billiger ist, diese Rohstoffe da zu kaufen. Wenn du den ganzen Transport- und Zollkosten und irgendwie Abfertigung, Qualitätskontrolle und so weiter und so fort mit einrechnen, musst du ja tun.
Na und vor allem würde ich mal die CO2-Kosten gerne einrechnen, dann bist du nämlich im negativen.
Nee, es geht um kleine, nur Tonnen, nicht hunderte Tonnen.
Also darum geht es ja nicht, dass es trotzdem Schiff in dem liefert.
Ja, da sind dann 25 Euro CO2-Kosten, das ist nicht so tragisch. Also das Problem ist, glaube ich, eher, dass die Kosteneinsparung, für die dieses Outsourcing in kauf genommen wird und diese Abhängigkeit in kauf genommen wird, ist erstaunlich gering. Ich meine, selbst wenn wir mal Huawei Base Stations nehmen, also nur mal so ein plakatives Beispiel zu nehmen, da fragt man sich ja, ok, die europäischen Operator nehmen ja irgendwie ganz schön viel Stress auf sich, um irgendwie zu sagen, so wir wollen lieber gerne Huawei Base Stations haben. Wie viel spart ihr denn da eigentlich so? Dann stellt sich raus, es sind halt so 20 Prozent etwa. Also vielleicht 25, manchmal 30, wenn es eine große Installation ist, die du halt sparst an Kosten gegenüber, wenn du bei einem anderen Hersteller kaufst. Das heißt, es sind jetzt nicht riesige Welten. Und dann denkt man sich so, okay.
Ja, aber das ist eine Runde Management Boni, ne?
genau. Und da ist, glaube ich, so ein bisschen mein Problem dabei, dass halt irgendwie der Staat nicht in der Lage ist, zu sagen, so okay, wir ersetzen mal Prioritäten und sagen halt, wir wollen halt bestimmte Technologien, wir wollen bestimmte Herstellungen, wir wollen bestimmte Kapazitäten halt in unserem Einflussbereich haben. Und dann halt sagt, okay, entweder wir subventionieren mit oder wir geben Steuerleistung für oder wir geben kostenlose Kredite für die Produktion, für die Aufstellung der Anlagen.
Oder wir machen Strafzölle auf die Importer aus China.
Strafzölle auf die Importer aus China. Könnte man ja auch machen. Also jedenfalls, dass halt der, der Wille zu sagen, wir wollen gerne technologische Souveränität in bestimmten Bereichen entweder aufrechterhalten oder wieder aufbauen, indem wir dafür sorgen, dass es halt durchaus lohnt, diese Anlagen hier aufzubauen, ist halt nicht da. Und das ist halt das, was mich gerade sehr stört, weil an vielen Stellen wäre es nämlich mittlerweile sogar so, dass du dadurch, dass der Kram einmal nach China outgesourct wurde, denn irgendwie 10, 15 Jahre vergangen sind, wenn du die Anlagen jetzt wieder neu aufbaust, baust du dann einen wesentlich höheren Automatisierungsgrad auf. Das heißt, du hast halt, also du hast höhere Kosten durch umweltauflagen, das ist richtig. Also gerade im Chemiebereich ist schon so, dass Chemie in China ist billiger, weil du weniger umweltauflagen hast. Aber alles, was halt so Arbeitsstückkosten-Dings ist, ist in vielen Fällen dadurch, dass du halt extrem viel mehr automatisieren kannst. Gerade diese ganzen Laborantenkram, also kontinuierliche Prozesskontrolle in der Chemieindustrie ist mittlerweile sehr stark automatisierbar. Also hast du halt so inline-Testing-Systeme, die automatisch laufen können, wo du halt nur noch relativ wenige Leute brauchst, damit du extrem viele Personalkosten sparen kannst.
Na, aber Chemie ist doch eigentlich ein traditioneller Standort.
Ja, sollte man denken.
In Deutschland?
Warte mal, nur dass ich das richtig verstanden hab. Wir haben gerade Lieferengpässe von Precursor aus China. Das gibt es ja wohl nicht. Wie? Und deswegen gibt es jetzt hier demnächst einige Medikamente nicht mehr oder was?
Jetzt schon.
What the fuck?
genau. Und es ist jetzt nicht so, dass es halt irgendwie so Zeug ist, wo du sagst, okay das geht hier nicht, weil bla oder so. Also das ist halt irgendwie, wenn jetzt irgendwie in die große Chemieform hingehen, sagen sie das wollen das herstellen, dann dauert das halt ein paar Wochen, dann haben die Anlagen konfiguriert und können das halt tun. Also sie tun es halt nicht, weil es lohnt halt nicht, weil die Weltmarktpreise sind halt so niedrig, weil die Chinesen das Zeug halt billiger produzieren. Also kaufen das halt nicht jeder. Und diese Art zu denken, die halt im Kalten Krieg noch da war, wo es halt eine Senatsreserve gab, wo es halt irgendwie klare Pläne dafür gab, wo halt Zeug herkommt, wenn halt irgendwie Probleme auftreten, wo es halt vollständige Übersicht darüber gab, wie die Medikamentenversorgung aussieht, welche Firma was herstellt und in welchen Mengen und so weiter und so fort. Also Standard-Zivilschutz muss man so sagen, also quasi so Aufrechterhalten der staatlichen Daseinsvorsorge. Die ist halt komplett weg gemarktwirtschaftet worden. Also das gibt es halt jetzt einfach nicht mehr, weil wenn wir halt Anzüge brauchen, dann gehen wir halt auf den Markt und kaufen die. War halt so die Denke. Die haben gesagt, so Senatsreserve brauchen wir nicht, weil die Firmen bevorraten das dann schon.
Niemand bevorratet freiwillig irgendwas.
Liebend. Warum denn auch? Es gibt ja kein, es gibt halt irgendwie ein paar Ausnahmen, gibt halt irgendwie so diese Mineralbevorratung, wo es halt staatliche Verpflichtungen gibt. Und die müsste man offensichtlich langsamer überdenken, die halt auszuweiten, weil mittlerweile stellt sich halt raus, dass eine Menge Sachen kritisch sind, wo du dich eben nicht darauf verlassen kannst, dass halt, wenn halt China ausfällt, du überhaupt noch in der Lage bist, halt irgendwie den Kram ranzukriegen, den halt brauchst, um so eine Krise zu managen. Und ganz ehrlich, was ich jetzt so gerade bei dieser Corona-Geschichte denke, ist, das Problem wird nicht so sehr die Seuche sein. So, also das wird halt im individuellen Einzelfall halt irgendwie wahrscheinlich ziemlich unschön werden, so für die betroffenen Menschen, weil ich nicht sicher bin, dass das Gesundheitssystem in der Lage ist, halt irgendwie damit klarzukommen, mit so großen Mengen Anfallzahlen und so blöd, wie das organisiert ist hier gerade. Aber die Panik davor und was jetzt halt passiert in den ganzen Lieferketten und wie halt irgendwie die gesamte ökonomische Aktivität runtergefahren wurde, schon allein deswegen, weil jetzt diese ganzen Großveranstaltungen abgesagt werden. Ich meine, die haben jetzt die ITB abgesagt, die internationalen Tourismusbörse. Alle möglichen anderen Veranstaltungen werden entweder abgesagt oder verschoben, so weil sie sagen, wir wollen nicht so viele Menschen auf einen haufen haben. Ist ja durchaus sinnvoll. Also wenn du sagst, okay, du willst halt irgendwie die Infektionskurve abflachen. Darum geht es ja gerade. Es geht jetzt nicht mehr darum, nur die Infektion zu verhindern, sondern nur dafür zu sorgen, dass nicht zu viele Menschen auf einmal erkranken, damit das Gesundheitssystem noch einigermaßen mitkommen kann. Das ist jetzt das erklärte Ziel von dem, was da draußen passiert. Also wenn die halt sagen, wir versuchen noch den Infektionsketten hinterher zu laufen, rauszukriegen, wo die herkommen, um so ein bisschen Containment zu machen und Quarantäne und so. Das Ziel ist nicht mehr zu verhindern, dass sich der Virus gesamt weltweit ausbreitet. Das Ziel ist dafür zu sorgen, dass die Verbreitung so langsam ist, dass das Gesundheitssystem noch mitkommen kann. Das heißt also, die Kurve wird nach hinten gestreckt und der Peak in der Mitte wird irgendwie abgeflacht.
Und die Supply Chains, da mach ich mir fast mehr Sorgen gerade. Wir waren ja gerade im Supermarkt und haben hier mal Survey gemacht, was ausverkauft war. Und das waren einmal die Nudeln, der Reis.
Tomatenmark und Mehl. Und Ravioli-Dosen.
Ja. Und da haben wir, wir sind jetzt hier gerade bei einer Start-up-Sendung. Wir haben noch ein zweites Geschäftsmodell entwickelt, nämlich dass wir Prepper-Ansteckung verkaufen, dass wir sozusagen als Dienstleistung einen Typ in deinen Supermarkt schicken. Und der lädt sich dann so mit Prepper-Scheiß irgendwie den einkaufswagen vor und fährt damit dann durch den Supermarkt. Und die anderen Leute, die sehen den dann und fangen dann auch an, Hamster zu kaufen und dein Profit geht durch die Decke.
genau. Falls du deine Supply-Chain wieder im Griff kriegst, dann noch Nachlieferungen.
Geschäftsmodelle für 500.
Ja, fiese Geschäftsmodelle für 500. Ja, ich meine tatsächlich ist vorratskaufen ansteckend. Also richtig cool fand ich ja die eine Supermarktkette, die mittlerweile schon vorgefüllte einkaufswagen hinstellt.
Was? Und somit mit?
So Vorratspack oder so 99 Euro. Einmal sind vollgestapelten einkaufswagen mit irgendwie was da halt so.
Was wir mal wegmussten bei uns.
Ja, was wir dann unter Prepping irgendwie verbuchen oder so. Also.
Das ist ja auch geil. Da kannst du mal die ganzen Sachen verklappen, die du nicht losgewonnen bist.
hauptsache sie haben ein langes Schleifleifdatum.
Also, naja, also ich glaube, es ist ja alles sehr unerfreulich, muss ich dir sagen. Ich dachte, wir machen hier mal eine aufbauende Sendung. Wir sind doch für unsere optimistischen Zukunft Aussichten bekannt.
Ach so, wir haben optimistische. Ja, stimmt. Ja, also in einem Monat fängt die Sommerzeit an.
Also die Mortalität ist ja relativ klein bei dem Coronavirus bisher.
Ja, wobei man da halt sagen muss, dass wir nicht genau wissen, wie die unbehandelte Mortalität aussieht. Weil wir haben ja irgendwie, glaube ich, so was wie 14 Prozent oder so der Fälle sind halt irgendwie behandlungsbedürftig, was halt schon relativ viel ist.
Ja, aber nur zwei Prozent sind gestorben oder so. Also die Schranke war relativ hoch.
Über alle Erkrankten hinweg, die diagnostiziert wurden.
Allerdings, was ja auch relativ krass ist, dass es so eine Art Wiederansteckung gibt.
Oder dass der Virus halt irgendwo schlummert, wo er halt nicht durch die Tests im Rachen erwischt wird.
Das ist halt mal richtig scheiße. Also das Leute, die sich angesteckt und wieder erholt haben, dann plötzlich wieder krank wurden.
Und dann ist tatsächlich...
Das ist so der schlimmste Fall für unser Gesundheitssystem, wenn die Leute dann alle irgendwie, ich fühl mich aber schon wieder krank.
Ja und vor allen Dingen sieht es halt so aus, als wenn halt bei dieser zweiten oder dritten Ansteckungswelle die Mortalität höher ist. Weil es dann halt heftiger wird.
Das ist aber der Endboss bei Plague Inc.
Ja, ich glaube, da gibt es noch keinen Model für, oder?
Doch, natürlich. Plague Inc. Da hast du dann die Mortalität... Du hast also der Trick zum... Soll ich vielleicht das erklären? Plague Inc. Da spielst du einen Pathogen und du musst versuchen, die Welt zu infizieren. Und der Trick, wie man da gewinnt, ist, dass man am Anfang eine kleine Mortalität, aber eine hohe Ansteckung hat und eine möglichst lange Inkubationszeit, bevor Symptome auftreten. Und später evolviert man dann die Tötlichkeit. Und da war dann immer der Joke, ja, das funktioniert ja so nicht, aber vielleicht haben wir jetzt den ersten Fall, wo jemand mit einem Pathogen, wo jemand später die Mortalität hoch evolutioniert hat.
Du meinst, wir haben eigentlich ein besoffenes Area, in dem es mit uns Plague Ink spielt?
Ich glaube, es ist ja schon länger klar, dass wir in einer Simulation wohnen. Jetzt wissen wir, in welcher Art von Simulation wir wohnen.
Du meinst, wir leben in der Plague Ink Simulation?
genau.
Ja, das ist natürlich unschön. Verdammt. Zumal heißt es halt, wenn es dann beim ersten Mal nicht funktioniert, dann irgendwie, probieren Sie nächstes Mal eine andere Strategie.
Gut, das haben wir aber schon länger. Wir haben ja erst den Typ gehabt, der hat ja auch gelernt, der Simulationsbetreiber hat uns erst die Pest gegeben, die hat viel zu schnell gemordelt. So, dann Ebola, das war auch viel zu schnell.
Die spanische Grippe war noch dazwischen.
Ja, es gab eine Menge. Und jetzt ist der Sweet Spot.
Da wissen wir noch nicht genau, was sieht zumindest schon mal so einigermaßen so aus, als wenn es der Sweet Spot werden könnte.
Tja, hat man da Gasgardin-Hafen schon zugemacht?
Ich weiß nicht, mussten wir auf die Karte gucken. Es gab ja diese, vom John Hotkins Institute, gab es ja dieses schöne Plaguing-Style, der sport über, wo die Infektionen schon sind.
Ja, aber die gesamte China war ein großer Roter.
Ja, nur noch ein großer Roter Blob. Also zur Erklärung dieses, irgendwie Madagaskar und den Hafen ist halt so ein...
Das war ein Mem aus dem Spiel. Madagaskar war sozusagen das schlimmste Land, weil es nur per See und per Luft erreichbar war und weil die Regierung immer sehr einen Triggerfinger hatte.
Also was heißt schlimmste Land? Also das Land, was am schwersten durch zu infizieren war, weil man halt aus der Sicht von des Pathogens spielt und man die ganze Welt infizieren musste, gab es halt immer wieder das Problem, dass wenn man halt zu schnell die Symptome hochgedreht hat, dass dann Madagaskar halt einfach seinen Hafen und seinen Flughafen zugemacht hat und dann hat man halt nicht die ganze Welt durchinfiziert bekommen. Und dann, ja, deswegen hat es halt so dieses, gab es halt dieses Präsident Madagaskar-Mem.
Ja, und es gibt, und es gibt das Mem, wenn Madagaskar irgendwie wegen Krankheit irgendwas zu macht, dann alle so, oh Scheiße.
genau.
Wir spielen gegen einen erfahrenen Spieler. Tja, gut, also so viel zu den optimistischen Aussichten.
Ja, ich meine, es ist halt so ein bisschen problematisch mit den optimistischen Aussichten, weil die...
Wir tun ja unser Bestes.
Also ich vermute mal, dass irgendwie die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es da eine große Wirtschaftskrise gibt, nicht so ganz klein ist. Weil die... Also wenn man sich so die Zahlen der chinesischen Output-Produktion anguckt und die Container-Shipping-Zahlen und so, das sieht halt nicht so gut aus. Und was wir halt schon auch so sehen, ist, dass halt so die ganzen Lieferketten halt wegbröseln. Also dass halt irgendwie dann so die Preise für Elektronikbordteile so 20, 25 Prozent schon hoch sind. Teilweise kriegst du bestimmte schrauben einfach nicht mehr, weil die halt auch aus China kamen und dann sind die jetzt alle.
Goldene Zeiten für die Debatte, wie wir die technische Souveränität wiederherstellen.
Ja, wäre jetzt eigentlich an der Zeit genau dieses zu tun, nur bräuchte man dafür halt natürlich ein großes Konjunkturprogramm. Also dann müsste man halt hingehen und sagen, okay, wir haben gerade eine schwarze Null, habe ich gehört. Perfekte voraussetzungen. Wenn ich jetzt der Staat wäre, dann würde ich jetzt hingehen und sagen, so hier sind meine 25 Bereiche, wo ich gerne Souveränität wiederherstellen würde.
Die Liste haben wir schon von den Kritis-Unternehmen.
Stimmt. Und dann lobe ich dafür halt tatsächlich Start-up-Förderung aus, also im Sinne eines Investments. Gibt ihr halt der KfW oder irgendeine andere Bank, die halt so ein Investments tätigen kann. Und dann werden halt diese Firmen wieder hochgezogen. Und die unterliegen halt der einzigen Beschränkung, dass sie halt in Deutschland produzieren müssen und nicht an ausländische Firmen verkauft werden dürfen.
Zur Not, würde ich sagen, in der EU.
Und dann sollen die halt irgendwie ganz normale Marktwirtschaft betreiben. Und wenn sie halt irgendwie mit den Preisen für die Produktion in Deutschland oder EU halt irgendwie nicht klarkommen, dann müssen sie halt einfach einen Ausgleich dafür kriegen, dass halt irgendwie die Souveränität erhalten wird. Also letzten Endes wird es halt auf ganz viele Lieferketten zutreffen. Also nicht nur bei Pharma. Also wir haben, da gibt es halt so Mängelerscheinungen gerade, dass du zum Beispiel bestimmte Silikondichtungen nicht kriegst, weil die einzigen Hersteller für in China sitzen so. Und die sitzen halt da irgendwo in Wuhan. Und dann gibt es die halt einfach gerade nicht, weil da geht halt niemand zur Arbeit, weil es ihnen verboten worden ist.
Ist ja auch gut so.
Ja, weiß ich nicht genau.
Naja, also es gab ja gerade die...
Ich kann den Scheiß doch einfach kurz durch Isopropazin und einfach in Container tun, weil das doch ganz so schlimm...
Gab es da nicht gerade die Untersuchung, dass das die einzige Maßnahme war, die wirklich geholfen hat, war, dass die Leute zu hause bleiben und der Public Transport irgendwie...
Ja, das ist tatsächlich richtig. Also, dass er sich den öffentlichen Nahverkehr irgendwie einzustellen war, offensichtlich das größte Maßnahmenpaket, was irgendwie wirklich geholfen hat. Und ich meine, die Frage ist halt, ob sie das in Deutschland bringen. Also, wenn man sich jetzt halt irgendwie das Rhein-Ruhr-Gebiet gerade anguckt, wo es halt irgendwie... Sie es halt versäumt haben, muss man einfach mal klar sagen, den Karneval zu verbieten. Deswegen... Naja, muss man jetzt gerade mal sagen.
Ja, das geht nicht in Deutschland.
So, die haben jetzt halt den Karneval nicht abgesagt und jetzt haben sie da halt einen mehr anderen und metastasierenden Cluster von Erkrankungen.
Inkubationspool.
So, und dann ist halt die Frage, naja, was machst du denn? Dann stellst du dann halt irgendwie den Rhein-Ruhr-Verkehrsverbund ein.
Ach, das ist das Ruhrgebiet, da haben wir nicht so viele Hörer, glaube ich. Hoffe ich. Liebe Hörer, wenn ihr immer ein Ruhrgebiet seid, bleibt da bitte.
Bin da nicht so sicher, ich muss da auch irgendwann demnächst wieder hin. So, also das ist halt irgendwie so. Aber das ist halt so die Frage, wie invasiv kann so ein Staat halt agieren? So, also soll halt irgendwie man dann sagen, okay, wir schalten jetzt die Wirtschaft ab, weil, ich meine, de facto ist, wenn du halt den öffentlichen Nahverkehr ausmachst, dann hast du damit halt dein produzierendes Gewerbe ausgeschaltet und zwar ziemlich komplett.
Ach, wir haben doch Auto.
Klar, sicherlich. Also, die Hälfte der Leute kommt sicherlich noch zur Arbeit, aber dann kannst du halt die Wirtschaft nicht betreiben. Und dann stellt sich halt schon die Frage so, wie gewichtet man solche Risiken? Also, sagst du als Staat, okay, ich nehme halt in kauf, dass ich halt irgendwie da halt irgendwie so eine gewisse Durchseuchung der Bevölkerung mit den entsprechenden Todeszahlen habe, dafür, dass meine Wirtschaft weiterläuft?
Naja, die aktuellen Prognosen sind ja, dass das eh einmal die gesamte Welt infizieren wird und wir werden halt damit leben. Da sterben jetzt halt irgendwie so und so viel Prozent der Leute, aber das passiert ja auch sonst, dass Leute an irgendwelchen Krankheiten sterben. So, das war so das Modell, was ich gesehen hatte.
Ja klar, das ist halt eine der möglichen.
Also Containment ist sozusagen gescheitert.
genau, die Frage ist jetzt halt nur, ob sie es halt so weit gestreckt bekommen, dass irgendwie bis das Wetter warmer und sonniger wird, was dann halt irgendwie hoffentlich die Ansteckungszahlen reduziert wegen UV und warm. Ob das halt so weit möglich ist, dass man halt irgendwann sagen kann, ok so Mitte Mai können wir wieder auf Normalzustand schalten.
Mitte Mai gehen wir wieder raus.
Oder keine Ahnung, ja ich weiß es nicht genau. Also ich glaube ja, dass halt irgendwie natürlich ein Großteil der Sachen, die jetzt passieren werden, werden halt bestimmte Trends beschleunigen. Also zum Beispiel halt so Videokonferenzen, Telepräsenz. Finde ich total super. Werden halt sicherlich einen massiven Boost erleben. Die Leute werden sich dran gewöhnen, dass es eigentlich gar nicht so verkehrt ist und funktioniert. So was halt irgendwie dazu führen wird, dass auch und zwar für weniger geflogen wird, was ich jetzt auch nicht so schlecht finde, wenn ich so irgendwie gucke, was da so jeden Tag irgendwie rumfliegt an irgendwelchen Consultants, die für zwei Stunden Meetings halt irgendwie ans andere des Landes fliegen, was du halt problemlos halt irgendwie auch mit einer Videokonferenz erledigen könntest, also das könnten tatsächlich sogar positive Auswirkungen sein, also dass Telepräsenz und Videokonferenzen halt irgendwie zunehmen. Auf der anderen Seite ist natürlich halt irgendwie so ein massiv eingeschränktes Sozialleben ist natürlich eigentlich auch scheiße. Also das ist halt irgendwie jetzt auch nicht so der Haar der Brüller, also.
Naja, aber manchmal muss man eben auf die Situation reagieren.
Naja, ich bin jedenfalls nicht besonders optimistisch, dass unser Staat da besonders gut drauf reagiert. Also dazu ist er halt einfach glaube ich zu inkompetent.
Nee, aber man lernt ja aus Sachen, die schiefgehen. Und ich glaube gelegentlich muss einfach was schiefgehen.
Du meinst danach wird es besser? Das klingt so ein bisschen wie die Theorie von einer Notwendigen Verschärfung des Klassenkampus als voraussetzung für die Revolution.
Ja, hat auch gut funktioniert, oder?
Scheiße.
Verdammt. Gut, also auf dieser positiven Endnote lassen wir euch dann mal solche Vorbereitungen zu Ende führen.
Ja, also falls ihr uns noch irgendwie ein bisschen was spenden wollt, da gibt es diesen Patreon-Button und wir nehmen auch immer noch Cryptocurrencies, dann hoffen wir, dass wir euch nicht in allzu deprimierter laune hinterlassen haben. Es wird ja immerhin langsam ein bisschen heller und wärmer da draußen und man kann sich irgendwie dann nachts auch allein in den Park setzen.
Es ist viel zu warm sogar.
Stimmt. Also was mir heute so auffiel war, dass die die Pollenflug-Saison schon angefangen hat, was natürlich extrem ungünstig mit irgendwie alle zusammen, wenn irgendjemand Nies zusammenfällt. Naja, Heuschnupfen halt, ne?
Ja, also stimmt. Jetzt soll es das. Ich mach schon die ersten. Verdammt.
Ja, das war so ein bisschen blöd.
Naja, also ich muss ja sagen, dieses Global Warming, das ist schon nachteilig. In Berlin haben wir eigentlich immer schön Frost gehabt im Winter. Und der hat dann alle Mücken gekählt und die motten. Ja, und die sind dann langsam über das Jahr hat sich das wieder vermehrt und so, aber die sind dieses Jahr sind die nicht tot.
Nee, die sind nicht tot.
Das wird also ein eher unangenehmer Winter. Auf der anderen Seite ist bei uns eher Sommer. Auf der anderen Seite ist der Sommer bei uns inzwischen so trocken, dass sie vielleicht deswegen sterben.
Ja, beziehungsweise meine ich, gut, die Insekten sind ja sowieso weniger. Also keine Ahnung. Vielleicht könnten ja auch die Insekten nicht so lästig sind, wie die Mücken mehr werden. Das wäre irgendwie ganz gut. Ach so, noch, noch, wir sollten zumindest noch irgendwie aus der Kategorie Service, Hörerservice, Desinfektionsmittel. genau, also wir verlinken noch den, das Rezept für von der Weltgesundheitsorganisation, für wie man sich sein Viruzid des Desinfektionsmittel selber brauen kann. Die Bestandteile sind relativ simpel. Man braucht eigentlich nur Isopropanol oder reinen Alkohol und halt irgendwie ein bisschen Wasserstoffperoxid und ein bisschen Glycerin und ein bisschen Wasser, möglichst abgekocht oder destilliert. Kann man sich also alles selber mixen, muss man nicht irgendwie 60 Euro für irgendwie eine Flasche auf Ebay ausgeben oder 100 mittlerweile sogar, weil so ob noch was zu kriegen ist. Problem, was man halt immer bedenken sollte, ist, wenn man halt die Ethanol-Variante wählt. Also es gibt zwei Rezepte davon, eins mit Isopropanol, eins mit Ethanol. Wenn man nicht Trink-Ethanol nimmt, dann hat man also sowas wie Brennspiritus oder Bio-Ethanol. Die sind vergelbt. Das heißt also, da ist ein Geruchs- und Geschmacksstoff drin, der ist für den menschlichen Konsum ungeeignet macht. Also es schmeckt bitter. Und das Problem ist, dass dieser Geschmack, dieser bittere Geschmacksstoff, setzt sich halt auf der haut ab. Das heißt also, wenn man sich ein Desinfektionsmittel mit Bio-Ethanol oder mit Spiritus macht, sollte man es besser nur zum Wischen des Infizieren von Türklinken und so weiter und so fort verwenden und nicht für die Hände. Weil wenn man dann mit den Händen halt seine Stulle anfasst, dann hat man halt so einen komisch bitteren Nachgeschmack irgendwie dann von den Händen auf dem Essen drauf. Ja.
Und noch vielleicht ein Safety-Hinweis, dass Peroxid und Luzerin, wenn man das online bestellt, kann es sein, dass man Besuch von den Behörden kriegt, weil die glauben, dass man eine Bombe bauen will.
Nein.
Fast alle Terrorgeschichten haben sie immer behauptet, dass sie gerade aus Peroxid eine Bombe bauen.
Ja, nimmt das 3%ige Peroxid.
Nehmt also nicht die Familienpackung mit dem hoch, nehmt nicht das hoch angereicherte.
Nicht das 30- oder 60-prozentige, nehmt einfach das 3-prozentige, das ist vollkommen ausreichend. Und wie gesagt, Glycerin gibt es einfach so, ist in den beauty-abteilungen auf Ebay oder Amazon relativ gut günstig zu beziehen. Und wie gesagt, beim Desinfizieren muss man bedenken, damit es wirksam ist. Es reicht halt nicht einfach damit einreiben, sondern es muss halt irgendwie so was wie irgendwie 30 bis 90 Sekunden feucht auf der haut stehen, damit es tatsächlich wirklich wirksam ist. So, ne? Also es sollte so reichlich nehmen davon. Das ist halt irgendwie der wichtige Teil dabei. Und dann nicht danach am Handtuch irgendwie, was schon irgendwie zwei Wochen lang im Bad hängt, abtrocknen, sondern einfach verdampfen lassen. Das hätte ich drauf. Ansonsten hilft tatsächlich günstig Händewaschen mit Wasser und Seife. Und dann mit Papierentuch abtrocknen, nicht mit dem alten Handtuch, was da schon seit ewigen Zeiten hängt. Hilft tatsächlich auch ganz gut. Naja, die üblichen Sachen kennt ihr ja nicht, mit denen ins Gesicht fassen. Menschensammlungen meiden. Wenn es geht, öffentlichen Nahverkehr nicht so viel benutzen, damit man nicht so viel von den anderen Leuten irgendwie vorgerustet wird. Und diese ganzen Dinge. Also unter Händeschütteln. Also Händeschütteln ist mir tatsächlich ein persönliches Anliegen. Ich verstehe nicht, warum das immer noch nicht irgendwie sich durchgesetzt hat, dass man auch mit diesem Händeschütteln endlich mal aufhört. Also es gibt so viele andere schöne Formen der Begrüßung. Man kann sich zum Beispiel verbeugen. Es gibt den Ebola-Handcheck mit dem Ellenbogen. Es gibt den Iran. Den Iran.
Umarmen und ein Küsschen.
Nein, du machst immer so Dubs mit dem Ellenbogen. Dann gibt es diesen schönen Iranischen mit den Füßen. Den finde ich auch ganz nett. Es gibt jedenfalls Alternativen. Ich finde einfach so eine kurze kleine Verbeugung mit hinreichendem Sicherheitsabstand eigentlich die beste. In diesem Sinne wünschen wir euch eine schöne Quarantäne.
Bleibt gesund.
Bleibt gesund, genau.
Und bleibt uns treu.
Ja. In diesem Sinne dann noch bis zum nächsten Mal.